avant de commencer la séance des
questions au Gouvernement je voudrais
rendre hommage
à Léon Gauthier
Léon Gauthier avait 17 ans lorsqu'il
sera lié à au général de Gaulle
il avait 20 ans lorsqu'il rejoint les
1676 autres Français du commandant qui
est fait
21 ans à peine lorsqu'il débarqua sur
les rivages de Normandie le 6 juin 1944
il incarnait une jeunesse exemplaire
qui armée de son seul courage et du sens
du devoir se mit au service d'une cause
qu'elle jugeait supérieure à sa propre
vie celle de la paix
il s'engagea pour défendre notre pays et
ses citoyens par amour de la patrie et
fit preuve d'un dévouement sans faille
au service des valeurs de liberté
d'égalité de fraternité qui nous
unissent et nous dépasse
c'est à la jeunesse que Léon Gautier a
100 ans encore s'adressait en
infatigable passeur de mémoire en
ambassadeur de la paix
comme la rappeler Christophe Blanchet
député du Calvados qu'il a bien connu il
était
fier et heureux chaque 6 juin de
remettre leur béret vert aux jeunes
militaires inspirés par son engagement
chaque 6 juin on percevait dans son
regard une douleur et un souvenir d'un
ami tombé ce jour-là
puis son souvenir continuer à inspirer
les nouvelles générations
au nom de l'Assemblée nationale
j'adresse nos plus sincères condoléances
à sa famille à ses proches un hommage à
Léon Gauthier à son amour de la France à
son courage de jeune homme à sa sagesse
de vétérans je vous demande de bien
vouloir observer une minute de silence
je vous remercie
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement je voudrais avant de donner
la parole à notre première hauteur
saluer le retour parmi nous de Madame
Elisa réva qui est une agente de
l'Assemblée nationale qui devant la
plupart d'entre vous a eu un malaise et
qui a recouvré la santé
bienvenue à vous madame
merci beaucoup mes chers collègues
alors la parole est à madame la
Présidente Mathilde panot pour le groupe
la France insoumise
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre Naël 17 ans est mort
abattu par un policier qu'un jour plutôt
à lucen Camara décédé dans les mêmes
circonstances depuis ces événements
atroces vous n'avez posé aucun acte
politique pour répondre aux problèmes
qui se dressent face à nous comment un
jeune de 17 ans peut-il être tué par un
policier en République française
pourquoi 16 personnes ont-elles trouvé
la mort depuis un an et demi en France
pour refus d'obtempérer quand
l'Allemagne n'en compte qu'un mort en
disant et le plus glaçant combien de
Naëlle n'ont pas été filmées à présent
pour justifier l'inaction vous versez
dans le déni vous m'avez dit hier les
émeutes que connaît le pays n'ont rien à
voir avec la mort de Naël pire vous
voulez faire peser sur nous la
responsabilité de la colère quand elle
prend racine dans un meurtre odieux
madame la Première ministre ni les
interpellations ni la répression
deviendront tarir la soif de justice de
la jeunesse seule une réponse politique
et de nature à apaiser durablement le
pays le retour au calme ne se décrète
pas il se construit lorsqu’alliance
police est l'une ça parle d'entrée en
guerre contre des nuisibles il ne parle
plus la langue de la République voici ce
qui devrait interpeller fortement votre
gouvernement et les relais d'opinion
dans ce pays
regardez la situation en face madame la
Première ministre il faut un débat à
l'Assemblée nationale quand
prendrez-vous au sérieux les
propositions que nous vous faisons
êtes-vous oui ou non favorable à
l'abrogation du permis de tuer de la loi
Cazeneuve qui a provoqué l'explosion du
nombre de morts en cas de refus
d'obtempérer allez-vous oui ou non créer
un comité vérité et justice pour faire
toute la transparence sur les cas de
violence policière allez-vous oui ou non
créez un fond d'indemnisation pour les
commerçants et collectivités victimes
des événements de cette semaine
comptez-vous enfin dépayser les affaires
de violence policière et allonger la
formation des policiers madame la
Première ministre cet ordre établi n'est
plus tenable
la parole
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un peu de silence s'il vous plaît madame
la Première ministre vous avez la parole
madame le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la
Présidente Mathilde panot
comme vous comme de nombreux Français
j'ai été ému et choqué par la mort d'un
jeune de 17 ans la semaine dernière à
Nanterre je l'ai d'ailleurs dit au Sénat
très clairement dès mercredi dernier le
gouvernement a fait preuve de la plus
grande transparence dans cette affaire
et la justice établira toute la vérité
mais madame la Présidente panneau dans
un moment comme celui que nous
traversons oui nous devons regarder la
réalité en face
car depuis une semaine face aux
violences qui ont éclaté je cherche vos
condamnations et j'entends des excuses
avec votre partie vous instrumentalisez
un drame vous refusez de condamner
clairement les violences vous refusez
d’appeler au calme alors que nos
policiers et nos gendarmes luttent pour
préserver l'ordre républicain alors que
des sapeurs-pompiers combattent des
incendies alors que des mers sont au
côté des habitants et sont la cible de
violence
des mairies et des écoles sont
incendiées des magasins pillés des élus
et leurs familles attaquées et vous vous
cherchez des coupables partout dans
toutes nos institutions républicaines
sauf chez les auteurs de violence
alors vous auriez pu comme vos alliés de
la nupesse exprimez votre émotion à la
suite du décès d'un jeune de 17 ans
demandé justice et appeler sans
ambiguïté au retour au calme mais vous
et les autres parlementaires insoumis
vous avez choisi un autre chemin celui
de l'outrans celui de la brutalité
verbale celui de l'excuse constante de
la violence
alors madame la Présidente panot quand
vos députés rejettent tout appels au
calme vous sortez du champ républicain
quand une de vos députés affirment que
la fin justifie les moyens vous sortez
du champ républicain
contre votre leader parle de permis de
tuer pour les policiers de peine de mort
pour les jeunes des quartiers et nous
traitent de chiens de garde vous sortez
du champ républicain
les violences madame la Présidente
panneaux rien ne peut les excuser et
pendant que vous jetez de l'huile sur le
feu pendant que vous donnez des excuses
au délinquants nous nous sommes engagés
pour rétablir l'ordre républicain et la
justice ne vient jamais de la violence
je vous remercie merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre la parole est à monsieur le
Président marlex pour le goplet
républicains
souvent mis par la haine de la France on
se met le chaos dans notre pays au nom
des députés de la République 1 je veux
dire notre soutien à ces milliers de
commerçants dont les magasins ont été
pillés je veux dire notre soutien à ces
milliers de Français dont les véhicules
ont été incendiés je veux dire notre
soutien au maire qui ont été pris pour
cibles et notamment à Vincent Jean Brun
et sa famille odieusement attaquée leur
domicile
et je veux dire notre immense
reconnaissance envers les forces de
sécurité policiers gendarmes policiers
municipaux sapeurs-pompiers et je pense
au caporal chef dame la cour
leur ex ordinaire sans froid et
l'honneur de la France aujourd'hui seul
une réponse pénale rapide et exemplaire
permettra d'endiguer la violence je vous
demande donc madame la Première ministre
de publier chaque semaine l'activité de
la justice département par département
combien de personnes interpellées
combien de personnes déférées à la
justice combien de personnes condamnées
le temps des excuses le temps des sursis
le temps de l'impunité est révolu
pour les mineurs notre code pénal
prévoit c'est l'article
l227-17 que les parents défaillants
puissent être condamnés à de la prison
ou à de fortes amendes quand on laisse
un gamin de 14 ou 15 ans dehors à 2h du
matin par une nuit d'émeute on doit
avoir sa responsabilité engagée c'est la
loi appliquez-la
la justice doit être rapide et je vous
demande de mobiliser ce qu'il faudra de
magistrats honoraires ou de magistrats à
titre temporaire pour juger toutes ses
affaires dans les 100 jours ne pas punir
serait une injure pour nos forces de
l'ordre ne pas punir ce serait ne pas
comprendre la gravité de la menace pour
la France ce serait empêché pour demain
de reconstruire la Concorde dans notre
pays il faut un changement de câble il
doit être radical il le faut maintenant
merci monsieur le président
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
président Olivier Marleix
depuis que des violences inadmissibles
ont éclaté nous avons travaillé sans
relâche au maintien de l'ordre
républicain sur tout le territoire avec
une volonté le refus de l'impunité
depuis le début des violences près de
4000 personnes ont été interpellées le
Garde des Sceaux a transmis une
circulaire de politique pénale au
parquet généraux leur demandant une
réponse rapide ferme et systématique
pour tous les auteurs et je vous
confirme monsieur le Président comme
nous l'avons évoqué hier que le garde
des sceaux demande notamment que des
sanctions pénales puissent être
prononcées par des parents qui laissent
leurs enfants de 12 ans de 13 ans de 14
ans traînez le soir mettre le feu à nos
mairies à nos commissariats
et au total hier soir près de 700
personnes avaient été déférées près de
800 garde à vue était en cours la
réponse pénale est au rendez-vous des
peines lourdes ont été prononcées
notamment de la prison ferme avec mandat
de dépôt d'ores et déjà 350 personnes
sont placées en détention j'ajoute que
le garde des sceaux adressera dans les
prochaines heures une circulaire sur le
traitement des infractions commises par
les mineurs d'abord pour que toutes les
atteintes même de plus faibles intensité
soit sanctionnée ensuite pour mettre les
parents face à leur responsabilité avec
des amendes des stages de
responsabilisation parentale et en
engageant le responsabilité pour
soustraction à leurs obligations légales
et j'ajoute que nous avons demandé au
parquet un suivi tout particulier des
violences et trop nombreux à l'encontre
des élus et nous avons demandé au
procureur de prendre l'attache avec
toutes les victimes
mais monsieur le Président Marleix notre
volonté d'une réponse pénale ferme d'une
justice plus efficace plus rapide et de
réponse plus adaptées pour les mineurs
c'est tout l'engagement du gouvernement
depuis 6 ans avec notamment la création
en 2021 d'un code de justice pénale des
mineurs et nous veillerons à sa pleine
mise en œuvre c'est aussi le sens du
projet de loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de la Justice
que vous examiniez actuellement et je
pense au recrutement de 10000 nouveaux
agents d'ici 2027 pour le ministère de
la Justice je pense à la simplification
de notre procédure pénale je pense à une
meilleure indemnisation de nos victimes
je pense à l'extension des travaux
d'intérêt général et je pense aussi bien
sûr au programme de construction de
nouvelles pralasses de prison d'ici 2027
dont vous débattrer dans les prochains
jours vous voyez monsieur le Président
de marlex nous voulons une réponse
pénale à la hauteur il ne doit y avoir
aucune impunité nous sommes mobilisés je
vous remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre
la parole est à Madame Aurore berger
président du groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente dimanche soir
un homme de 24 ans est mort mort en
service pour nous protéger des émeutes
et de ses conséquences il s'appelait
Dorian d'un Malincourt et était
sapeurs-pompiers
[Applaudissements]
et désolé de vous dire que c'est tout
sauf hors sujet chers collègues parce
que depuis mardi dernier ce sont bien
808 policiers pompiers et gendarmes qui
ont été blessés à ceux qui crient au
soi-disant permis de tuer de nos forces
de l'ordre je le dis solennellement ils
ont et ils méritent notre soutien pour
leur action
parce que
la vérité mes chers collègues c'est que
oui le décès brutal d'un jeune homme ce
sera toujours un drame mais il est sans
rapport avec le déferlement de violence
brûler nos bâtiments publics des écoles
des mairies des bibliothèques tirées
avec des armes de guerre sur nos
policiers attendez à la vie de nos élus
et de leur famille piller des commerces
il y a aucune justice dans ses actions
et quand on est un responsable politique
on ne fait pas le tri entre ce qui peut
être brûlé ce qui ne peut pas l'être à
ceux qui osent dire que la fin justifie
les moyens à ceux qui ont des refuser
d'appeler au calme vous serez jugés
sévèrement par les Français nous devons
avoir un discours de vérité évidemment
pour les parents évidemment pour nos
jeunes qui doivent prendre conscience de
leurs actes et de ses conséquences un
discours de vérité aussi face à ceux qui
à l'extrême droite veulent faire croire
que nos quartiers se résumeraient à 7000
voyous armés venus pour casser nous leur
disons qu'ils ne sont pas et qu'ils ne
font pas nos quartiers parce que les
Français qui vivent dans nos quartiers
ce sont les premiers à pleurer devant
nos écoles détruites ce sont les
premiers à souffrir des dégradations et
ce sont les premiers à respecter la
règle à respecter la République et à
aimer la France merci beaucoup madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
quels sont les actions que votre
gouvernement va continuer à prendre pour
faire respecter notre République
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la
Présidente Aurore berger il y a une
semaine jour pour jour un jeune homme de
17 ans a été tué lors d'un contrôle
routier mais bien vite après ce drame
l'émotion légitime a été remplacée par
une violence inexcusable ce sont d'abord
les symboles de la République et de
leorité qui ont été spécifiquement visés
notamment les mairies les écoles les
commissariats les brigades de
gendarmerie ce sont ensuite des pillages
de magasins qui ont éclaté et dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche la violence
est montée d'un cran avec l'attaque du
domicile du maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses et
j'ai à nouveau une pensée pour Vincent
Jean Brun son épouse et ses enfants
face à ces violences notre priorité
c'est le retour de l'ordre républicain
et notre réponse s'est appuyée sur
quatre piliers d'abord la mobilisation
des forces de l'ordre avec 45 000
policiers gendarmes sur le terrain
deuxième pilier la fermeté de la réponse
pénale ensuite la responsabilité des
réseaux sociaux et enfin un rappel
nécessaire de la responsabilité et de
l'autorité parentale car les auteurs
sont jeunes voire très jeunes nous avons
nous avons agi guidé par un objectif
aucune impunité face aux violences grâce
à cette intervention forte et rapide de
l'état grâce à la mobilisation des élus
locaux les violences ont commencé à
diminuer à partir de samedi avec une
décrue très nette dimanche soir et
encore la nuit passée notre objectif a
été et reste de garantir l'ordre
républicain
nous sommes sur la bonne voie mais nous
restons extrêmement vigilants et ses
progressivement avec la plus grande
prudence que nous adapterons notre
dispositif de sécurité madame la
Présidente berger avec l'ensemble de la
majorité avec l'ensemble des élus
républicains nous sommes au côté des
policiers des gendarmes des
sapeurs-pompiers nous saluons la
mobilisation des magistrats nous sommes
aux côtés des mers et des huiles des
élus locaux qui sont en première ligne
et nous répondrons présents pour les
habitants pour les commerçants les
artisans pour les victimes de ces
violences comme le président de la
République nous y a invité nous devrons
aussi examiner toutes les causes de ces
événements et comme je l'ai dit hier à
l'ensemble des présidents de groupe nous
en tirerons toutes les conséquences avec
les groupes de la majorité et tous les
parlementaires de l'arc républicain je
vous remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Sébastien Chenu
pour le groupe rassemblement national
merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse aux garde des sceaux
il y a un an vous nous disiez ce sera
Emmanuel Macron ou le chaos aujourd'hui
c'est Emmanuel Macron et le chaos vous
nous disiez le vivre ensemble
aujourd'hui c'est le vivre avec nous
voulons adresser nous députés du
rassemblement national évidemment notre
reconnaissance notre gratitude aux
forces de l'ordre qui partout dans le
pays des polices municipales aux
gendarmes en passant par les pompiers la
police nationale ont défendu les
Français et leurs biens
nous voulons penser à tous ces Français
ces professionnels qui dans les
quartiers ou dans des villes moyennes
ont été victimes nous voulons vous dire
aujourd'hui que rien n'est le fruit du
hasard tout cela en réalité et le fruit
des politiques que vous menez depuis des
années que vous menez vous et vos
prédécesseurs mais il faut dire que
c'était les mêmes même politique même
logique même absence de résultats
votre responsabilité en réalité est
immense les Français attendent de la
rapidité attendent de la cohérence et
vous ne leur donnez que l'inverse depuis
tant d'années en 2005 déjà vos discours
rimaient avec des analyses sociologiques
et avec des rafistolages coûteux pour
les Français alors aujourd'hui vous vous
étonnez vous déplorez vous constatez que
des villes moyennes comme Denain comme
longe dans ma circonscription soit
attaqué il brûle ce qui fait symbole il
brûle la France qu'il déteste celle de
nos mémoires avec le Mémorial de la
Shoah Nanterre celle de notre laïcité en
brûlant des écoles celle de nos cultures
avec la France des Lumières en brûlant
nos théâtres il brûle notre façon notre
liberté à vivre ce que nous voulons en
brûlant le bar gay de Brest oui les
Français désormais refusent votre diktat
et vos intimidation morales à quel
moment allez-vous entendre nos
propositions comme celles de revenir sur
l'excuse de minorité pour les mineurs ou
les allocations familiales pour les
familles de délinquants entendaient les
propos de Marine Le Pen qui vise à
rendre à la peau français leur pays
merci beaucoup la parole est à monsieur
Éric Dupond-Moretti garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Chenu merci d'abord de ne pas
tenter de me rappeler des phrases que je
n'ai jamais prononcé et je vous mets
d'ailleurs ici respectueusement au défi
de me dire où et quand je les ai
prononcé 2005 je n'ai strictement aucune
responsabilité je n'étais pas en
politique vous étiez déjà à l'UMP
pour le reste
pour le reste comment voulez-vous
comment voulez-vous que je réponde à une
espèce de de s'imposium où vous évoquez
à la fois liberté individuelle et
déterminisme un point précis sur lequel
je peux vous répondre
l'excuse de minorité si vous y revenez
je vous indique tout de suite que le
Conseil constitutionnel vous censurera
monsieur le député c'est tout à fait
clair parce que le Conseil
constitutionnel souhaite qu'on fasse une
différence entre les mineurs et les
majeurs et je pense que certains peuvent
ici retrouver pour le reste le ministère
de l'Intérieur et le ministère de la
Justice ont fait front commun et ils ont
répandu de façon républicaine aux
troubles qui ont secoué bouleversé notre
pays
[Applaudissements]
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Monsieur Boris Vallaud président du
groupe socialiste
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre un adolescent est mort lors
d'un contrôle de police un adolescent
qui n'aurait pas dû mourir et nous
disons l'immense tristesse qui est la
nôtre à la famille de Naël et à ses
proches
depuis une semaine la France a connu des
nuits de violence dans de nombreux
villes de toutes tailles des pillages et
destructions des agressions et ses actes
nous le disons sont intolérables nous
avons accompagné aux premières heures
les appels au retour à la paix civile et
au respect de l'ordre public
nous pensons à toutes les personnes
policiers gendarmes pompiers commerçants
habitants de ces quartiers à nos mers
qui ont eu à connaître des agressions la
peur parfois la destruction souvent et
représentant de la nation nous devons
nous tenir résumant résolument aux côtés
de cela
mais nous savons qu'il n'y a pas d'ordre
sans justice voilà pourquoi devra venir
sans attendre l'heure des réponses
politiques un pays dans lequel des
milliers de jeunes personnes souvent
mineurs se lancent pendant des jours et
des nuits dans de telles équipées est un
pays qui va mal notre responsabilité
collective individuelle et de regarder
la vérité en face et d'en tirer toutes
les conséquences
ghettoïsation de certains de nos
quartiers pauvreté discriminations mal
logement disparition des services
publics mis en échec de nos institutions
sont autant de difficultés profondes
dont ces fréquents débordements de
violence fait d'une minorité sont aussi
un symptôme il faudra bien évidemment
remettre sur le métier le plan Borlo
abandonné soutenir dans la durée la
politique de la ville l'école les
associations et l'éducation populaire
nous devons aux françaises et aux
Français ou qu'ils vivent la République
partout et pour tous enfin nous devons
avec sérénité et sérieux traité de la
question du rapport entre une part de la
population et la police qui n'a cessé de
se détériorer comme nous ne pourrons pas
ignorer non plus la question de l'usage
des armes c'est à dire de l'évulation de
la loi que nous réclamons madame la
Première ministre nous ne pouvons
comprendre cette excusée ce n'est pas
excusée comprendre c'est à dire dans la
justice et la paix que comptez-vous
faire madame la première la première
ministre vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Boris Vallaud
je tiens tout d'abord à vous remercier
car vous avez condamné sans ambiguïté
les violences qui ont touché de
nombreuses communes et appelées à la
paix civile à la différence de vos
alliés insoumis
et monsieur le Président vano j'entends
vos interrogations sur les racines de la
crise et les réponses que nous pouvons
apporter notamment au travers de la
politique de la ville cette réflexion de
plus long terme elle aura lieu mais je
peux vous dire que nous n'avons pas
cessé d'agir pour les quartiers et pour
la politique de la ville depuis 6 ans
depuis 2017 nous avons augmenté le
budget de l'Agence nationale pour la
rénovation urbaine portée à 12 milliards
d'euros nous avons mis en œuvre les
cités éducatives nous avons dédoublé les
classes de CP et de CE1 et déployer
100000 emplois francs au bénéfice des
habitants des quartiers alors oui nous
devons mener une réflexion s'il vous
plaît sur les causes de cette crise avec
tous les groupes politiques de l'arc
républicain dans ces moments notre
responsabilité c'est l'écoute des
propositions des élus notamment des élus
de terrain c'est aussi assumé
collectivement la complexité du sujet et
construire des réponses efficaces avec
chacun et c'est notamment le sens de
l'échange que le Président de la
République a en ce moment même avec près
de 300 maires dont les communes ont été
touchées par les violences comme nous
avons eu l'occasion d'en parler hier
monsieur le Président nous sommes encore
mobilisés et concentrés sur le retour de
l'ordre républicain et la réparation
mais je vous l'assure monsieur le
Président Vallot nous sommes déterminés
à continuer à agir pour les galaxies à
nos services publics et pour l'égalité
des chances surtout notre territoire je
vous remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre
la parole est à Madame Cyrielle
châtelain présidente du groupe
écologiste
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre chers collègues de
Marseille à Héricourt de Montargis à
Lyon d'Échirolles à Nanterre dans tous
les territoires abandonnés des villes
aux campagnes la révolte a déchiré la
France car voilà 18 années que les
politiques échouent 18 années depuis la
mort de Zied Bena et Bouna Traoré et
aujourd'hui c'est Naël qui est tué
18 années de stérilité de
rationalisation et de disparition des
services publics 18 années durant
lesquelles le contrat républicain a été
bakoué s'il vous plaît car la réalité
madame la Première ministre est qu'en
France aujourd'hui certaines vies valent
moins que d'autres certains territoires
valent moins que d'autres en France
l'égalité est un concept théorique
brûler des écoles pillées des magasins
agressés des élus ne seront jamais des
actes de justice la violence ne pourra
pas être la solution c'est pourquoi nous
écologistes nous membres de la nups nous
ne nous résignions pas un monde où
certains ont tout et d'autres ne sont
rien il n'y a pas de fatalité notre
responsabilité est d'avoir une réponse
politique d'abord l'acte d'apaisement
annoncer la modification de la loi de
2017 annoncer le retour de la police de
proximité et mettez en place
immédiatement des mesures de lutte
contre les discriminations et contre le
racisme ensuite l'humilité les
politiques ne répondront jamais réussir
seul écoutez-les les fonctionnaires les
associations de terrain les mers et les
parents pas seulement deux heures en
période de crise mais toute l'année et
enfin investissez dans la jeunesse il
nous faut une vraie politique de
jeunesse et faites de l'école publique
une priorité sans une école qui
fonctionne pas de qualité madame la
Première ministre quand cesserez-vous
d'être pétrifiée et comprendrez-vous
enfin les mesures fortes pour recréer et
réparer et recréer les liens que vous
avez laissé se désagréger
[Musique]
la parole
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la
Présidente Cyrielle châtelain vous
l'avez rappelé il y a une semaine le
drame de la mort d'un jeune homme de 17
ans lors d'un contrôle routier a
beaucoup choqué à travers notre pays
face à ce drame les viols les réponses
viendront de la justice et pas de la
violence et vous l'avez dit vous-même
pourtant depuis une semaine des
violences inacceptables ont éclatées
dans certaines communes ces violences
vous les avez condamnées et je veux
saluer cette attitude républicaine qui
tranche avec celle de certains de vos
alliés mais madame la Présidente
Chatelain c'est violence n'ont rien à
voir avec une révolte des banlieues et
j'ai été madame la Présidente châtelain
à Nanterre à Garges-lès-Gonesse à Bezons
à Évry à L'Haÿ-les-Roses j'ai échangé
avec les élus et les habitants et deux
mots revenaient sans cesse
l'incompréhension et la colère la colère
vis-à-vis de ses auteurs de violence qui
met pas mal des politiques menées depuis
des années tous les efforts qui ont été
faits pour la politique de la ville
notamment dans le précédent quinquennat
pour rénover ses quartiers pour
reconstruire des équipements publics
pour renforcer l'accès aux services
publics dans ces quartiers et vis-à-vis
de la jeunesse madame la Présidente
Chatelain nous avons agi tout au long du
président précédent quinquennat nous
avons agi tout au long du précédent
quinquennat avec le développement de
l'apprentissage avec les emplois francs
avec aujourd'hui la réforme du lycée
professionnel donc madame la Présidente
Chatelain c'est violence sont
inexcusables elles ne représentent pas
la jeunesse de notre pays nous
accompagnons tous les Français tous les
jeunes dans tous les dans tous les
territoires de notre République je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Paul
Mattei président du groupe démocrate
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mardi dernier un drame
s'est produit avec la mort du jeune Naël
tram pour lequel c'est encore le temps
du deuil c'est aussi le temps de la
justice qui doit suivre son cours dans
le respect des principes de l'État de
droit
depuis des quartiers entiers dans nos
métropoles comme dans nos territoires se
sont enflammés plus de 5000 véhicules
incendiés 1000 bâtiments brûlés dégradés
ou pillés des centaines de mairies
services publics au commissariat attaqué
ces exactions doivent être condamnées à
toute force parce qu'elles détruisent
des biens communs elle détruisent des
familles entières et des experts de
nombreux acteurs qui sont tous les jours
sur le terrain l'État a répondu
rapidement et vigoureusement tant par le
nombre des forces de l'ordre mobilisées
que par les actions la justice très
rapidement mis en oeuvre je veux
d'ailleurs saluer ici le courage et le
sang froid des policiers des gendarmes
celui des pompiers bien sûr
mais je veux aussi saluer les mers
serviteur de la République qui ont été
au front jour et nuit depuis mardi ils
sont au centre de toute action ils sont
victimes souvent d'agressions et même
désormais ce sont leurs familles qui
sont en première ligne c'est
inacceptable
sans eux notre République n'est rien ou
bien peu de choses et je sais qu'ils
n'ont jamais l'esprit libre ils sont ils
ont à leur côté tous les bénévoles de
leur conseil municipaux le corps
enseignant et le monde associatif au
long de mon groupe démocrates modernes
et indépendants je veux partir mon
rendre hommage aujourd'hui au maire et
vous demandez madame la Première
ministre de leur apporter tout le
soutien dans le gouvernement est capable
il faut d'urgence leur donner les moyens
de reconstruire les médiathèques les
écoles les antennes de police tous ces
lieux qui font le cœur de notre
territoire et qui donne le sens aux mots
communiquer communauté
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
président Jean-Paul Mattei les épisodes
de violence de ces derniers jours
connaissent aujourd'hui une décrue
importante mais je n'oublie pas les
dégâts causés ce sont des mairies des
écoles des commissariats des brigades de
gendarmerie des postes de police
municipales et des bâtiments publics
vandalisés et parfois incendié ce sont
des commerces des bureaux de tabac
saccagés et pillés ce sont des voitures
brûlées c'est inacceptable et je vous
dire que nous sommes aux côtés de toutes
les victimes de violences de dégradation
ou de pillages et je l'affirme devant
vous nous veillerons à ce que les
collectivités territoriales souhaitent
accompagnées et puisse rapidement
remettre en état les équipements
détériorés les procédures seront
allégées et les délais réduits au
maximum et l'État viendra en soutien
lorsque c'est nécessaire c'est
précisément en ce moment même le
président de la République échange sur
ces questions avec des mers et nous
apporterons toutes les réponses à ces
mères pour qu'ils puissent au plus vite
remettre en service leurs équipements
publics et nous serons également aux
côtés des habitants des commerçants des
artisans des commerçants touchés
pourront notamment bénéficier de reports
de charge fiscales et sociales les plus
touchés pourront même bénéficier d'une
annulation de ces charges et bien sûr
nous demandons la mobilisation des
assureurs dont c'est d'abord la
responsabilité le ministre de l'Économie
Bruno Le Maire les a rencontrés samedi
dernier et hier encore les assureurs se
mobilisent ils se sont engagés à tout
faire pour faciliter la vie des victimes
de violence en prolongeant les délais de
déclaration de sinistre en accélérant
leur indemnisation et en réduisant les
franchises au cas par cas voyez monsieur
le Président Mattei nous voulons
reconstruire vite et nous serons aux
côtés des élus des commerçants des
artisans et de toutes les victimes de
violences je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la première ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Stéphane peu pour
le groupe GDR
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à la première ministre dans
son immense majorité le pays a dit son
indignation devant la mort du jeune Naël
et depuis mercredi je ne cesse de
croiser des gens en colère devant les
violences et les destructions
inacceptables l'heure doit être à
l'apaisement mais les appels à l'unité
et à la fermeté ne suffiront pas aussi
indispensable soit-il il ne faudra pas
regarder ailleurs une fois le calme
revenu je veux d'abord ici rétablir une
vérité non il n'y a pas de territoire
perdu de la République il n'y a
il n'y a que des territoires que la
République abandonne
ainsi
assis depuis 2005
ainsi depuis 2005 hormis la rénovation
urbaine tous ces dégradés notamment
l'école
qui devrait être la prunelle de nos yeux
et qui est le service public le plus
maltraité l'école est maltraité car les
moyens alloués par le biais de la
politique de la ville ne compense jamais
l'affaiblissement des politiques de
droits communs maltraités car dans le
secondaire il faudrait 45000 personnes
de plus pour retrouver le taux
d'encadrement de 2006 or en 6 ans vous
avez supprimé 8900 emplois
maltraités quand dans l'académie de
Créteil écoutez-moi bien on admet au
concours de professeurs avec une note de
4 sur 20 alors que le seuil est de 14
sur 20 dans le reste de la France et
qu'en plus on s'apprête à pourvoir les
postes par le recrutement sur leboncoin
ou par des jobs dating ce n'est ce n'est
pas ça l'école de la République Monsieur
le Ministre nous croyons encore au mot
de Victor Hugo selon lesquelles quand on
ouvre une école on ferme une prison nous
croyons que l'école est une partie de la
solution ma question quelle mesure
entendez-vous
merci beaucoup le temps est largement
dépassé la parole est à Monsieur Papen
Diagne ministre de l'éducation nationale
et de la Genèse
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Stéphane peu non la République
n'abandonne aucun territoire l'éducation
nationale n'abandonne aucun territoire
elle n'abandonne pas les filles et les
filles de la République dans le
département que vous
citez la scène Saint-Denis les moyens
d'enseignement à leur même que la
population scolaire va baisser
notablement l'année prochaine les moyens
d'enseignement restent au même niveau
et Monsieur le Député c'est pour cela
que nous augmentons
c'est est-ce que vous pouvez un peu de
respect d'abord pour les enseignants y
compris les enseignants contractuels
d'une part
laissez-moi m'exprimer un peu de s'il
vous plaît allez un peu de calme un peu
de calme monsieur le ministre vous avez
la parole que nous faisons en scène
Saint-Denis particulièrement ça a été
ça a été monsieur le député le
dédoublement le dédoublement des classes
de CP de C1 de grande section ça a été
les colos apprenants ça a été les 12
cités éducatives qui ont été créés ces
dernières années ce sont des moyens
d'enseignement supplémentaires se sont
bientôt l'ouverture de toute petite
section c'est aussi également les
horaires en scolaire et en périscolaire
étendu de si de 8h le matin jusqu'à 18h
c'est également à la rentrée 2024 les
bourses scolaires qui seront versées
automatiquement sans que les personnes
aient aller réclamer c'est enfin un plan
pour les 40 collèges les plus en
difficulté sur les 130 oui ça vous
intéresse pas à ma réponse et bien je
vous la donne parce que je m'intéresse à
la Seine-Saint-Denis et je n'en fais pas
un argument de politique politicienne
monsieur le député merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
allez un peu de silence la parole est à
Monsieur Bert trempe en chair président
du groupe liote
avec l'ensemble des députés du groupe
liote je voulais apporter mon soutien au
commerçants aux forces de sécurité de
secours et aux habitants qui ont été
touchés par les violences de notre pays
évidemment à la famille duchonel nous
condamnons toutes ces violences sans
réserve rien ne peut justifier
destruction et pillages il est une chose
cependant que j'ai appris de mes mandats
locaux l'action publique appelle
l'humilité
j'ai entendu des analyses de
pseudo-experts d'irresponsables
politiques alimentant les discours de
haine il n'y a pas de solution miracle
il y a une urgence le retour au calme
mais alors puis un chantier qui ne doit
plus être enterré celui d'une politique
de cohésion sociale on ne peut pas
traiter séparément les questions de
sécurité des réponses pénales des
discriminations d'accès à l'emploi de
santé ou d'éducation tout est lié il
faut prendre tous ces mots à la racine
proposer des solutions adaptées à nos
territoires j'ai relu rapport Borlo
travaillait avec 200 m et associations
il y avait un constat l'immobiliste à
l'immobilisme allait créer une nouvelle
crise nous y sommes il y avait
nombreuses réponses concrètes pour une
réconciliation nationale malheureusement
ce fut un rendez-vous manqué certes des
choses ont été faites mais si peu nous
avons une crainte que les solutions
partielles soient mises en place et que
l'on passa autre chose et qu'une autre
crise survienne au contraire il faut des
solutions globales forgées avec les élus
locaux les responsables associatifs
policiers médiateurs l'éducation
nationale nous avons appelé cela un
conseil des sages il convient donc de
reprendre le rapport Borlo madame la
Première ministre de l'actualisé les
valeurs de notre République ne peuvent
progresser que si la promesse d'égalité
possible ma question est simple quant
allons-nous construire enfin un destin
commun redonnant espoir à nos
concitoyens le président Macron y est-il
prêt en y associe en toutes les forces
vives de notre pays et enfin
reconstruire un monde plus humain plus
juste plus fraternel merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président la parole est à
madame la Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
président Bertrand pencher permettez-moi
d'abord de vous remercier pour votre
attitude profondément républicaine et
sans ambiguïté face aux violences
inacceptables qui ont eu lieu ces
derniers jours dans ces moments il est
essentiel que tous les élus attachés aux
valeurs de la République continue
[Musique]
à parler
oui vous avez un problème quand je parle
des élus attachés aux valeurs de la
République mesdames et messieurs les
députés
il est donc essentiel que tous les élus
attachés aux valeurs de la République
continue à parler d'une seule voix dans
un esprit républicain pour dénoncer les
violences les atteintes un qualifiables
aux élus et pour soutenir nos policiers
nos gendarmes et nos sapeurs-pompiers
alors comme vous je sais que le retour
au calme ne résoudra pas tout mais il
est le préalable indispensable à toute
action de long terme
viendra ensuite le temps des débats de
fonds mais je veux vous dire que pendant
six ans nous n'avons pas cessé d'agir
pour la politique de la ville vous
mentionnez le rapport de Jean-Louis
Borloo vous avez raison de le faire et
nous avons repris un grand nombre de ses
propositions nous avons conforté
l'Agence nationale pour la rénovation
urbaine en augmentant considérablement
son budget nous avons fait de
l'éducation et de la jeunesse des
piliers de la politique de la ville je
pense notamment aux cités éducatives que
nous avons créé pour lutter contre les
inégalités de destin et mieux structurer
les acteurs de terrain de la communauté
éducative je pense au dédoublement des
classes de CP et de CE1 que nous
étendons aux grandes sections et ça
n'est pas tout nous avons agi pour
l'emploi et si le taux de chômage est
encore trop élevé dans nos quartiers il
a baissé de 5 points depuis 2017 alors
monsieur le Président pencher nous
sommes déterminés à travailler et agir
pour nos quartiers pour tout nos
territoires et nous le ferons pour tous
les élus engagés pour l'unité de notre
pays je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la Première ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Laurent Marc
Angeli président du groupe horizon merci
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre notre pays a vécu ces derniers
jours des heures effroyables rien rien
ne peut justifier de s'attaquer à des
écoles à des bibliothèques à des locaux
d'associations qui œuvrent pour le bien
commun nos concitoyens voient leurs
voitures brûlées des commerçants leur
magasin pillés des policiers des élus et
parfois même de simples passants qui se
trouvent au mauvais endroit au mauvais
moment sont attaqués sauvagement je
tiens d'ores et déjà à saluer au nom du
groupe horizon et apparenté le travail
exceptionnel réalisé par nos forces de
secours et de sécurité elles ont souvent
été mobilisées sur des territoires qui
n'étaient pas les leurs dans les
conditions extrêmement difficiles que
nous connaissons tous
nous souhaitons aussi rendre hommage à
l'engagement sans faille dont font
preuve nos élus de terrain qui refusent
de reculer face aux menaces et
agressions mes chers collègues il n'y a
aucune revendication sociale à trouver
dans ces agissements inacceptables
aucune colère légitime aucune excuse
mais seulement un acte des actes de
Sécession d'une minorité qui rejette
toute forme d'autorité ces rejets de
l'ordre républicain se font au détriment
de dizaines de millions de Français qui
n'ont qu'une seule envie une seule
demande celle d'un cadre de vie paisible
pour eux et pour leur famille comment
par ailleurs ne pas être interloqué par
le jeune âge des individus interpellés
que font ces mineurs seuls parfois toute
la nuit dans la rue où sont leurs
parents titulaires de l'autorité
parentale et chargée de veiller tant à
leur éducation qu'à leur sécurité qui
surveille l'attitude et l'activité de
ces jeunes sur les réseaux sociaux et
sur Internet
madame la Première ministre notre
capacité à faire nation et gravement
menacé par ces événements récents
comment comptez-vous réaffirmer
l'autorité de l'État et la primauté du
pacte républicain face à des individus
qui semblent prêts à tout pour faire
régner le chaos merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président la parole est à madame la
Première ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
Président Laurent Marc Angelli vous avez
raison de le dire les violences de ces
derniers jours sont inacceptables et je
veux à nouveau rendre hommage à nos
policiers nos gendarmes nos
sapeurs-pompiers dont le courage est
exceptionnel face aux violences de ces
derniers jours
notre priorité c'est de garantir le
retour au calme et d'assurer la sécurité
de tous les Français et comme l'a dit le
président de la République nous devons
aussi engager une réflexion sur les
causes profondes de cette situation et
la représentation nationale il prendra
naturellement toute sa part nous
examinerons tous les sujets sans
exception sans tabou ni faux semblant
nous devons notamment assurer le respect
de l'autorité en général et de
l'exercice de l'autorité parentale nous
devons mieux réguler les réseaux sociaux
et vous aurez l'occasion d'examiner
prochainement un texte visant à mieux
sécuriser et réguler l'espace numérique
et comme l'a dit le président de la
République nous devons renforcer nos
réponses en fonctionnant les jeunes dès
le premier écart avec vous monsieur le
Président Marc Angeli avec l'ensemble
des députés de la majorité avec toutes
celles et ceux qui veulent construire
des solutions
refuseront les caricatures et les idées
toutes faites notre objectif c'est
l'efficacité dans les réponses ce sont
les solutions pour les habitants des
quartiers pour les habitants de tous nos
territoires et pour notre jeunesse notre
ambition c'est l'unité de la République
je vous remercie merci beaucoup madame
la Première ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Michael taverne
pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la présidente des dizaines
d'années d'Ermont d'idéologie voire de
soumission voilà les causes de la
situation dramatique qui touche notre
pays tous ceux qui se sont succédés au
pouvoir porte une part de
responsabilités dans ce chaos
souvenez-vous Emmanuel Macron avait
expliqué que ce serait lui ou le chaos
c'est pourtant bien sa politique qui a
accouché du chaos que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui ma question portera sur
l'aspect sécurité de ce chaos et
s'adresse aux ministres de l'Intérieur
l'événement tragique de Nanterre et les
émeutes qui en ont découlé dans tout le
pays ont démontré une nouvelle fois aux
yeux de millions de Français que tout
était prétexte à détruire incendier et à
piller des images insoutenables montrant
des écoles des médiathèques des crèches
des véhicules des mairies des transports
en commun partir en fumée condamnant
ainsi les habitants des quartiers et les
honnêtes gens qui en sont les premières
victimes à vivre dans la peur et le
chaos
le chaos sécurité qui a touché
l'ensemble notre pays s'inscrit bien sûr
dans le cas où migratoires que nous
subissons et contre lequel vous restez
les bras ballants malgré nos alertes
depuis des années le gouvernement
continue la politique de l'autruche et
cette réalité vous revient en pleine
figure vous-même monsieur le ministre
vous paraissez dépasser et déconnecter
en affirmant que dans la nuit de
vendredi à samedi l'intensité est
témoindre alors que c'était la pire
quelle visionnaire et je ne parle pas du
piétinant au plus haut sommet de l'état
de la présomption d'innocence de celui
qui servait la République sous
l'uniforme policier
face à ces prédateurs barbares qui
défilent l'autorité de l'État crache sur
la France et violent des élus a conçu
sursaut sécurité pour soutenir les
forces de l'ordre dans leur mission à
quand ce sur ce politique pour expulser
les délin étranger monsieur le ministre
que comptez-vous faire pour ce chaos
sécuritaire cesse et que l'autorité de
l'État soit enfin rétablie dans notre
pays
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Gérald Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer
madame la Présidente et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député
suite aux événements dramatiques de
Nanterre où je crois comme la première
ministre j'ai pu m'exprimer pour dire en
effet que toute la justice est vérité
doit être faite en respectant la
présomption d'innocence qui est due à
tous les citoyens et donc y compris aux
forces de l'ordre je veux ici dire
d'abord mon soutien aux 808 policiers
gendarmes et sapeurs-pompiers blessé et
évidemment à ce caporal chef
de la brigade des sapeurs-pompiers de
Paris
je crois monsieur le député que dans un
moment aussi terrible pour notre pays
il ne faudrait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
s'il vous reste le ministre répond
il faut se rappeler monsieur le député
que la République est un équilibre oui
l'ordre et la fermeté
oui l'ordre juste mais pas juste l'ordre
oui il faut écouter monsieur le député
les policiers les gendarmes qui
travaillent difficilement dans tous les
quartiers de la République et je suis je
crois le premier et soutenir oui
monsieur le député il faut aussi ne pas
confondre les débats moins de 10% des
4000 interpellés étaient étrangers
monsieur le député 90% étaient français
40 personnes seulement étaient éligibles
un centre de rétention administratif la
question d'aujourd'hui c'est ce des
jeunes délinquants pas des étrangers
nous sommes nombreux ici Monsieur le
Député être issu des quartiers à être
issus de l'immigration et à aimer notre
pays et nous ne voulons ni de la haine
des policiers ni de la haine des
étrangers mais nous voulons de l'amour
de la République
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
monsieur taverne le mépris qui vous
caractérise révèle bien au grand jour
votre incompétence la seule qui répondra
auprès de sécurité Sainte-Marine Le Pen
la seule qui mettra en place une
politique c'est Marine Le Pen plus que
jamais l'urgence c'est l'alternance
la parole
la parole est à monsieur Alexandre
vincendait pour le groupe les
républicains merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse c'est madame la
Première ministre en tant que député de
la 7e circonscription du Rhône avec
notamment les villes de Rillieux-la-Pape
Bron et veau en Velin j'ai été comme
beaucoup d'autres dans cette émission au
cœur du chaos de ces derniers jours
madame la Première ministre ma question
est double nos forces de sécurité police
nationale gendarmerie police municipale
et pompiers ont été héroïques la
République doit leur être reconnaissante
rappelez la responsabilité des parents a
également été salutaire la République
c'est des droits et des devoirs y
compris pour les parents et il est
urgent d'en tirer toutes les
conséquences
alors que les voyous font l'objet de
poursuite qu'entendez-vous faire à
l'encontre des émeutiers par procuration
ceux qui ont refusé d'appeler au calme
ceux qui à force de toute excuser en
permanence ont mis lieu de l'huile sur
le feu quitte à se rogner comme Monsieur
Mélenchon qui en 2012 fustigeait les
hordes de casseurs les traitants de
crétins de bouffon et de l'arbain de la
société capitaliste aujourd'hui il les
incite à la violence en sélectionnant
pour eux les cibles avisés les appels à
la sédition par des responsables publics
et politiques sont intolérables
la deuxième partie de ma question madame
la Première ministre concerne la
politique de la ville et lui mère de
Rillieux-la-Pape en 2014 nous avons
engagé un plan de rénovation urbaine
sans précédent l'argent est là le
problème c'est que les procédures sont
trop longues le temps d'action est trop
long et entre les temps les décisions
prises en 2014 les premiers effets ne se
sont ne se font sentir que 10 voire 20
ans après c'est long tellement long et
complexe que ça devient illisible pour
nos concitoyens qui vivent comme moi
dans ces quartiers qui pour l'immense
majorité d'entre eux font tout pour
vivre dans la dignité et le respect de
la République cela décrédibilise la
parole publique et laisse le champ libre
voyou et à ceux qui les
instrumentalisent aussi madame la
Première ministre que comptez-vous faire
pour aider les maires à faire plus vite
plus fort et plus efficacement je vous
remercie merci beaucoup bonsoir collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Vincent des
ce matin
allez lisez plus de 200 m de toute
sensibilité politique de toute taille de
commune aussi était autour du président
de la République pour partager leur
désarroi leur constat
et à entendre y compris
dans ce qui utilisent ce moment qui
devrait être un moment de dignité pour
lancer des phrases à la volée aux deux
extrêmes de cette émission je me désole
parce que le premier soutien que nous
devons leur apporter c'est celui
d'évoquer ces sujets avec un minimum de
respect on peut pas à la fois saluer les
fonctionnaires saluer les forces de l'or
salut les élus et quand on les évoque et
qu'on pose une question sur la manière
de les accompagner faire en sorte
d'utiliser des raccourcis ou faire en
sorte de pousser sa propre idéologie
sans prendre le temps à la fois
d'entendre ce qu'ils ont à dire et de ce
que cette réalité alors ces mères
qu'est-ce qu'ils disent ils disent qu'il
y a des lourdeurs administratives ils
disent qu'il faut faire en sorte de pas
jeter la politique de la ville avec
l'eau du bain et qui a des réussites des
dizaines de milliards d'euros qui ont
été investis ont permis dans un certain
nombre d'endroits de permettre des
réussites et que dans le même temps
c'est pas parce qu'on a ces images qui
sont terribles qu'il faut qu'on occulte
les histoires et les parcours qui ont pu
être
le problème c'est que quand une famille
s'en sort qui la remplace une famille
qui est à nouveau et parmi les plus
fragiles et être capable de regarder
cette réalité en face ces mesures
l'ampleur du combat pour la mixité on
gagnera si on est tous ensemble et je
veux vous rejoindre sur les silences
indécent de l'extrême gauche de
Mélenchon parce que ce sont ces silences
qui ont contribué à mettre le feu aux
poudres et je vous le dis dans ces
quartiers les habitants méritent plus
que vous les traitiez comme des
émeutiers en puissance votre mépris de
classe pour les habitants du quartier
populaire il éclate dans la façon dont
vous les instrumentalisez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Sacha Houlier
du groupe Renaissance merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Eric Dupond-Moretti garde des
sceaux monsieur le garde des sceaux ces
derniers jours partout en France
d'importantes émeutes ont suivi la mort
de Naël je veux bien sûr ici redire mon
soutien à sa famille une enquête de
l'IGPN a été ouverte et la justice est
saisie ce drame aussi grave soit-il ne
peut servir au prétexte à l'incendie que
nous avons constaté je salue à cet égard
l'attitude responsable de la majorité
des élus qui ont appelé au calme à
l'exception notable d'un quarteron que
dis-je d'un groupe huskule des lus qui
s'est durablement discrédité je parle
bien sûr de la France insoumise
mais ce que nos concitoyens attendent
aujourd'hui c'est de la justesse dans le
prononcer de la justice monsieur le
garde des sceaux en moins d'une semaine
les forces de l'ordre ont procédé à plus
de 3000 interpellations les prévenus ont
été déférés devant les juridictions et
ont fait l'objet de procédure de
comparution immédiate compte tenu de la
gravité des faits pouvez-vous nous faire
connaître les instructions que vous avez
données au procureur afin qu'ils soient
intraitable dans leur réquisition
pouvez-vous nous indiquer si ces
demandes ont été suivies par les
magistrats et nous faire connaître la
nature des peines prononcée contre les
émeutiers pouvez-vous nous dire si nous
disposons de suffisamment de magistrats
pour juger ses faits massifs et nous
assurer contrairement aux vieux mensonge
de l'extrême droite que ces peines
seront bien appliquées comme le son 95%
des peines prononcées
monsieur le garde des sceaux ses
émeutiers sont jeunes souvent mineurs
parfois ils ont dit sept ans d'autres 14
ou même 12 vous avez posé la question
d'autorité parentale vous avez eu raison
la médiation parentale dans les
quartiers populaires méritera à cette
petite à ce titre d'être renforcé mais
dans cette attente quelles instructions
avez-vous donné pour s'assurer que les
parents ne laissent pas traîner leur
fils enfin comme le président de la
République vous avez pointé la
responsabilité des réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la fermeté de la réactivité et je dois
dire que l'encre de la circulaire était
à peine sèche que déjà les procureurs la
mettait en œuvre et je veux ici de façon
solennelle le rendre hommage parce
qu'ils ont été au rendez-vous
rendez-vous de la Justice de la même
façon je veux rendre hommage au
magistrat du siège au greffier qui
pendant des heures et des heures
ont répondu
ont répandu à ces actions insupportables
et voilà ce que nous avons fait d'abord
j'ai demandé au procureur qu'il requiert
et c'est possible depuis 2021 auprès des
réseaux sociaux pour que l'on trouve les
noms et les adresses naturellement des
utilisateurs il y a pas un gamin qui
peut et qui doit encore penser
aujourd'hui qu'il peut échapper à sa
responsabilité ensuite la responsabilité
des parents il y a des parents
voyez-vous
il y a des parents voyez-vous qui sont
en capacité d'exercer l'autorité
parentale et qui ne l'exerce pas non
être à 12 ans dans la rue ça n'est pas
normal et je viens de mettre en place
dans une autre circulaire un certain
nombre
un certain nombre de directives pour
qu'on rappelle à l'ensemble des parents
les obligations qui sont les leurs enfin
naturellement la justice a été au
rendez-vous de la fermeté que j'appelais
de mes vœux 350 incarcérations ont été
prononcés voilà ce que je voulais dire
mais nous avons besoin de la justice la
justice monsieur le ministre merci
la parole est à Monsieur Antoine léoman
pour le groupe la France insoumise
si madame la Présidente Monsieur
Darmanin ce vendredi les syndicats
factieux alliance et une sapolis sont
menacés le pouvoir exécutif dans un
communiqué après avoir menacé les
pouvoirs législatifs et judiciaires
c'est un nouveau cap qui est franchi
quand rappellez-vous à alliance que la
police n'est pas là pour donner des
ordres mais pour servir et obéir la
vérité c'est que vous êtes paralysé par
la peur vous avez peur de finir comme
Monsieur Castaner limogé en 48 heures
pour avoir dénoncé les clés des
tremblements vous avez peur de fermer la
cagnotte de la honte lancée par un
raciste pour récompenser le meurtrier de
Naël vous avez peur que la police se
retourne contre vous après l'avoir
utilisé pour faire passer en force votre
réforme des retraites voilà ce qui
arrive quand on fait reposer l'autorité
de l'état non sur l'adhésion mais sur la
répression cette peur paralyse votre
action cette peur est celle qui vous
empêche d'agir quand l'ONU dénonce le
racisme dans la police mais vous nier ce
racisme est la présidente macronise de
l'Assemblée dit que la police exerce sa
mission d'une façon merveilleuse au nom
de Tahiti Gabriel Samy qui vit gangali
Mohamed si jeune de ma circonscription
âgée de 13 à 17 ans je veux vous parler
de cette merveille ferme ta gueule tête
de chien tu veux qu'on t'encule ou quoi
ces propos sont ceux de policiers à ces
jeunes gens il vous choque tant mieux
peut-être que vous allez réagir le code
de déontologie dit que le policier doit
se comporter d'une manière exemplaire
qui inspire en retour respect et
considération pensez-vous que ces
insultes inspirent respect et
considération pensez-vous que quand ces
syndicats policiers par le dehors de
sauvage de nuisibles et de guerre ils
emploient autre chose qu'un vocabulaire
raciste car la guerre c'est contre un
ennemi de l'intérieur il n'existe pas en
république d'ennemis de l'intérieur
le racisme est un délice et le poison de
la République quand allez-vous limoger
et punir les policiers racistes qui
salissent l'uniforme de leur collègue
républicain quant allez vous faire
justice aux jeunes comme tahitien qui
résume eux leur attachement à la
République par une phrase simple on est
tous français on doit avoir les mêmes
droits merci beaucoup
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez un peu de silence monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député il ne faut pas tout confondre un
policier établi en examen tous les
policiers n'ont pas été mis en examen
des délinquants de certains quartiers
ont mis un sac des villes tous les
habitants des quartiers n'ont pas mis un
sac les villes
des syndicats de police et mettre des
communiqués non monsieur le député le
ministre de l'Intérieur ne corrige aucun
communiqué d'aucun syndicat qui viennent
de FO de la CGT ou d'alliance
une cagnotte a été ouverte il faut la
fermer non monsieur le député il
appartient comme pendant les gilets
jaunes comme pendant les attentats à la
justice de notre pays et notamment au
tribunal de grande instance de pouvoir
fermer cette cagnotte
monsieur le député
faites mentir la phrase de Jacques Brel
vous n'êtes pas en effet des
révolutionnaires vous êtes des petits
révoltés soyez au rendez-vous de la
République
merci beaucoup monsieur ministre
la parole est à Madame marée Noël
Baptiste pour le groupe socialiste
[Musique]
alors
mes chers collègues vous venez de poser
une question Daniel écouter la question
suivante madame baptistel vous avez la
parole merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse au ministre de la
Santé de la prévention question après
question les parlementaires de tout bord
vous font remonter chaque semaine les
inquiétudes de nos concitoyens sur
l'accès à la santé à l'hôpital à la
campagne ou en ville les mêmes constats
de carence sont tirés permettez-moi
aujourd'hui d'attirer votre attention
sur l'accès aux soins de gynécologie
médicale qui est sinistré dans notre
pays et même impossible dans 13
départements comme le relève récent
rapport du Sénat de la DDF manque de
cils spécialiste traitement insuffisant
des violences obstétricales et
gynécologique couverture inégale du
territoire sont autant de sujets qui
touchent prioritairement les femmes et
qui nous concernent toutes et tous ici
tant les conséquences que cette pérennie
pénurie engendre son multiple d'un point
de vue sanitaire et social entre 2020 et
2020 la France a connu une baisse depuis
de 50% de ses effectifs de gynécologues
médicaux professionnels de santé
association féminisme parlementaire font
le constat de la nécessité d'aller plus
loin plus vite et de prévoir une
augmentation significative du nombre
d'interne dans cette spécialité ce
déficit si nous ne faisons rien s'aggra
on constate déjà des conséquences
néfastes pour de nombreux fans des
absences de suivi des retards avérés
dans les diagnostics et au final des
pertes de chances notre amendement
transpartisan de régulation à
l'installation aurait pu être un début
de réponse au problème des désirs
médicaux dans toutes les disciplines
vous y être refusé monsieur le ministre
permettre une prise en charge
gynécologique efficace des femmes
contribue à leur émancipation alors
pouvez-vous nous dire si vous allez
consentir à ouvrir plus de poste
d'interne en gynécologie médicale dans
le cadre de l'Examen Classant National
pourra rentrer 2023 comment comptez-vous
reconstituer durablement les effectifs
de cette profession alors qu'à l'horizon
2030 nous pourrions encore perdre 20% de
nos spécialistes et enfin envisagez-vous
d'accroître le cadre des compétences des
sages-femmes en matière de prescription
par l'extension du décret du 5 mars 2022
je vous remercie merci beaucoup ma chère
collègue la parole est à François Brown
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Baptiste le manque de professionnels de
santé est un véritable défi pour notre
système de santé ce manque de
professionnelle de santé malheureusement
quel que soit les spécialités vous
parlez de la gynécologie médicale mais
c'est aussi les autres spécialités et
quand même la résultante de quelques
dizaines d'années de gestion totalement
aveugle des effectifs médicaux et
paramédicaux alors nous avons supprimé
numerus clausus nous avons maintenant
plus de 15% de d'étudiants qui sont
acceptés en deuxième année de médecine
nous avons aussi renforcé les formations
en infirmière en lien avec les régions
plus 6000 postes de formation
d'infirmières plus 3000 postes de
formation d'aide soignante nous avons
également un enjeu majeur sur ces
infirmières c'est l'abandon pour 10%
d'antenne des études c'est pour cela que
nous venons de lancer une réforme
complète du métier et de la formation
infirmière pour les maintenir dans les
territoires et dans les formations en ce
qui concerne
les réponses que nous pouvons apporter
au-delà de ces chiffres qui ne formeront
des médecins que dans 10 ans et bien
l'enjeu majeur est de redonner du temps
médical redonner du temps médical aux
professionnels c'est leur supprimer
toutes les tâches qui sont inutiles en
tout cas pour lesquelles n'ont pas de
plus-value c'est le cas du plan pris en
février sur les 15 Stach inutiles c'est
aussi favoriser l'exercice
pluriprofessionnel pour revenir et
coordonnées bien entendu pour revenir
sur ce que vous disiez concernant les
sages-femmes et les gynécologues
médicaux et bien l'élargissement des
compétences sages-femmes permet là aussi
tout de suite d'apporter une réponse au
niveau des territoires où nous manquons
de gynécologues et puis au-delà de ce
partage de connaissances l'exercice
coordonné par l'aide par des assistants
médicaux permet d'augmenter on le sait
déjà de 10%, les potentiels de patients
pris en charge par un médecin sans
travailler plus donc voyez il y a des
réponses sur deux niveaux il y a des
réponses pour augmenter le nombre de
professionnels quels qu'ils soient dans
toutes les spécialités et la gynécologie
médicale comme la gynécologie
obstétrique en profitera de la même
façon et également redonner plus de
temps professionnel au médecin pour
qu'il puisse prendre en charge plus de
patients
pour le groupe Renaissance merci madame
la Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Gérald Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer
je n'en veux pas à la police mais
seulement à une personne celui qui a ôté
la vie à mon fils voici les mots
prononcés par la maman de Naël ces mots
ont trouvé une réponse auprès de notre
justice parce que oui le policier
l'homme en question a été effectivement
mis en examen pour homicide volontaire
et placer sous des tensions provisoires
il devra répondre de ses de ses de ses
actes et c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a
rappelé le président de la République la
première ministre le garde des sceaux et
vous-même monsieur le ministre parce que
oui et cela vous a peut-être vous
déplaît mais nous sommes dans un état de
droit et c'est ainsi que nous
fonctionnons dans un État de droit
cet État de droit qui malheureusement
depuis un an un an souffre des amalgames
des exagération
menses d'une partie des bancs de cette
hémicycle qui préfèrent se rouler en
boule dans des polémiques plutôt que de
faire de la politique et oui je parle de
vous mesdames et messieurs de la France
insoumise ne vous en déplaise nous
continuerons à nous lever à nous dresser
pour que notre République continue
d'exister et défendre ses valeurs et
nous ne le faisons pas seul nous ne le
faisons nous le faisons grâce à l'action
l'action résolu de ces femmes et ses
hommes qui sur le terrain au quotidien
continue à nous protéger et assurer
notre sécurité je parle bien évidemment
de nos forces de l'ordre alors monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer ma question est simple comment
s'il vous plaît comment face à ce chahut
ce chaos voulu par certains avez-vous
encore à trouver les mots pour rassurer
ces hommes et ces femmes ces engagés du
quotidien pour qu'ils ne démissionne pas
qu'il n'abandonne pas qu'il ne désespère
pas parce que oui une partie de la
représentation nationale aujourd'hui
préfère les pointer du doigt au risque
de les menacer merci beaucoup ma chère
collègue la parole est à Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée
les 250 000 policiers gendarmes et
pourraient avec le ministre des comptes
publics rajouter les douaniers plus les
policiers municipaux font un travail
extrêmement difficile et on le sait tous
exigeant dangereux ils sont les filles
et les filles du peuple qui passent des
concours subissent une formation sont
particulièrement regarder par leur
hiérarchie particulièrement regarder
comme ayant des responsabilités et sont
donc à ce titre et c'est tout à fait
normal dans un souci de déontologie
d'exigence et lorsqu'ils respecte pas la
République lorsqu'il respecte pas ses
exigences de probité de déontologie ils
sont sanctionnés ils sont parmi les
agents publics les plus contrôlés comme
je voulais déjà dit ce n'est pas madame
la députée parce qu'il y a du tumulte
parce qu'il y a du brou à et parce que
la politique politicienne que l'on doit
distinguer les morts le drame de
Nanterre
toute la nation le pleure je pense aussi
à Mélanie Lemay cette gendarme du
Lot-et-Garonne tué par un refus
d'obtempérer à 26 ans
je pense aussi à Romain boulange ce
jeune policier de la circonscription de
l'île qui laisse une orpheline de 7 ans
dans la cour de la commissariat parce
qu'un chauffard ne s'est pas arrêté
mesdames et messieurs les députés on ne
doit pas se rejeter les morts d'un camp
à un autre on doit respecter les règles
de la République pour tous les citoyens
qui soient ou non policiers et je veux
dire ici qu'il n'y a pas de bande
rivales il n'y a pas les policiers et
les voyous il n'y a que la République
qui doit parler à tous les citoyens sans
dit que ça Sion de race de religion et
de croyances et il devrait y avoir
uneanimité politique pour combattre ceux
qui mettent le feu sur les écoles et qui
dira bourg pourtant sur les forces de
l'ordre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur Benjamin Lucas
pour le groupe écologique
merci madame la Présidente
Fabrice Fernandez Zied Bena Bouna Traoré
Lamine diang Luigi du Kennet Rémi
Fraisse Adama Traoré Abubakar Fofana
Zineb Redouane Steve Maya camiso Cédric
chouvia Mohamed gapsi ah oui c'est une
camarade
c'est non ce sont des vis arrachés des
familles endeuillées des villes
meurtries par une mémoire traumatique
que le temps néfaste jamais quand vous
nier la réalité des violences policières
ou des contrôles aux faciès vous refusez
de porter un regard lucide celui que
doit avoir une grande démocratie comme
la nôtre sur le réel alors pour que les
mêmes causes ne produisent pas les mêmes
effets allez-vous enfin reconnaître la
réalité madame la Première ministre et
mettre autour de la table les citoyens
les élus locaux les associations les
éducateurs les fonctionnaires de police
et étudier enfin les propositions pour
établir un lien de confiance entre toute
la population et la police républicaine
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
la présidente monsieur député monsieur
le député qu'il faille améliorer sans
cesse le travail des agents publics et
singulièrement des forces de l'ordre
c'est une évidence c'est cette majorité
vous ne l'avez pas voté qui a augmenté
de 4 mois la formation des gardiens de
la paix il fallait augmenter la
formation des gardiens de la paix à coup
sûr c'est cette majorité et vous ne
l'avez pas voté qu'augmenté de 50% la
formation continue des policiers c'est
cette majorité et vous ne l'avez pas
voté qui a mis dans la loi que lorsque
un policier ou un gendarme était
responsable de violences conjugales ou
avaient trafiqué condamné par la justice
ou avoir des propos racistes xénophobes
ou homophobes devaient être exclu de la
fonction publique et vous ne l'avez pas
voté monsieur le député soyez
constructif aidez-nous soyez aussi si
vous voulez j'ai entendu tout à l'heure
le président Vallot honnête c'est la
majorité socialiste qui a voté la loi de
février 2017 c'est la majorité
socialiste
qui dans des circonstances difficiles
c'est rendu compte que les policiers les
gendarmes parce qu'à l'époque il y avait
sans doute une gauche républicaine qui
était en responsabilité devaient leur
permettre d'être tous les jours face à
ceux qui voulaient tuer du flic et quel
est le rapport lorsqu’un policier ne
respecte pas la loi de la République
lorsqu'il respecte manifestement pas les
dents ontologies qu'on doit jeter au
chien tous les autres policiers de
France quel rapport de la modification
de la loi dans l'émotion lorsque c'est
un policier qui a fauté vous disait vous
dites sans doute tous les jours qu'il
faut arrêter légiférer secoue l'émotion
ça vaut pour tous les citoyens y compris
pour les policiers monsieur le député
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
monsieur Lucas
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
c'est parce que justement nous voulons
accompagner les fonctionnaires de police
que nous pointons votre responsabilité
celles des gouvernements successifs
celle des responsables politiques dans
une organisation du maintien de l'ordre
et des opérations de policière qui
conduit plus de morts qu'ailleurs en
Europe qui est un problème aujourd'hui
systémique pouvez-vous nier pouvez-vous
nier dans ma circonscription à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou 150 lycéens ont été
parqués les mains sur la tête filmées
par des forces de l'ordre avec cette
phrase Voici une classe qui se tient
sage que il n'y a pas de violence
policière pouvez-vous affirmer à un
jeune qui est contrôlé 7 ou 10 fois plus
qu'un autre à la raison de la couleur de
sa peau qu'il n'y a pas de contrôle
discriminatoire monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur une démocratie adulte elle
pose tous les problèmes sur la table et
elle les affrontent le regard ouvert
avec conscience des chiffres de la
réalité des enquêtes journalistiques et
les enquêtes sociologiques elle ne fait
pas d'une Trump merci monsieur le
ministre
monsieur député oui j'écoute les
habitants et les élus par exemple
Mantes-la-Jolie où je me suis rendu où
le maire demande-la-jolie dans votre
circonscription réclame plus de
policiers oui monsieur le député moi moi
qui est élu c'est une vie populaire je
sais que c'est avant tous les habitants
des quartiers populaires qui ont besoin
de sécurité et le nier c'est laisser les
habitants du quartier populaire voter
rassemblements national alors qu'ils ont
votaient à gauche chapitre longtemps
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Thomas aménagé
pour le rassemblement national
merci de la présidente comme ceux qui
les ont précédés Emmanuel Macron et son
gouvernement font une fois encore la
terrible démonstration de leur
incapacité totale à protéger des
Français du chaos qui frappent notre
pays je me souviens des propos du
candidat Emmanuel Macron qui expliquait
que ce serait lui ou le chaos c'est
pourtant bien sa politique qui a
accouché du chaos que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui ma question portera sur
l'aspect économique de ce chaos et
s'adresse au ministre de l'économie et
des finances dans la nuit de jeudi à
vendredi la ville de Montargis où je
suis élue a été victime de véritables
scènes de guerre dans cette commune de
14000 habitants pourtant épargnés par
les épées par les émeutes de 2005 trois
immeubles ont été détruits ravagés par
les flammes 80 commerces vandalisés et
pillés par des hordes de jeunes
racailles plus aucun territoire n'est
donc désormais à l'abri de l'an
sauvagement à Montargis comme dans de
nombreuses petites villes c'est tout un
tissu commercial qui est aujourd'hui à
l'arrêt dans un contexte économique
difficile après la crise sanitaire et
alors que l'inflation explose les
commerçants ont besoin de mesures bien
plus ambitieuses que l'annonce de report
de charge et de la diligence des
assurances et des banques ils attendent
des mesures fortes pour se voir
indemniser des pertes liées aux périodes
où ils ont été contraints de fermer pour
leur sécurité mais surtout les pertes
liées à la baisse de fréquentation à
moyen terme qui touche tous les
commerçants des centres-villes concernés
monsieur le ministre nos commerçants ont
ras le bol ils sont en colère comprenez
leur ras-le-bol leur ras-le-bol de ceux
qui se lèvent tôt pour aller travailler
qui font vivre au centre bourg et qui
ont vu leur outil de travail détruit en
une nuit par de jeunes sauvages leur
ras-le-bol de ceux qui financent par
leur travail et avec leurs impôts les
aides sociales dont bénéficient certains
parents de ces casseurs monsieur le
ministre que comptez-vous faire pour
venir en aide aux commerçants et éviter
ce nouveau chaos économique dans nos
territoires merci beaucoup monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur Bruno Le
Maire ministre de l'Économie des
Finances de la souveraineté industrielle
et numérique
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
ménager en 5 jours ce sont plus de 1000
commerces qui ont été saccagés pillées
pour certains incendiés tous ces actes
sans exception sont un qualifiables
injustifiable et inexcusable j'étais ce
matin à Arpajon avec la ministre en
charge des PME Olivia Grégoire et nous
avons d'abord ressenti l'émotion
profonde des commerçants mais leur
confiance aussi notre capacité à
répondre à leurs besoins d'indemnisation
comme nous l'avons fait tout au long de
toutes les crises que nous avons
traversées depuis plusieurs années nous
n'avons jamais laissé tomber les
entrepreneurs les commerçants nous ne
les laisserons jamais tomber
cela fait trois jours que nous négocions
avec les assureurs des demandes précises
auxquelles les assureurs ont répondu ils
étendront le délai d'indemnisation et de
dépôts de plainte il permettront d'avoir
des réductions de franchise pour les
commerçants indépendants qui ont été les
plus touchés et ils apporteront des
réponses simples et rapides à l'ensemble
des commerçants
s'agissant
s'agissant de l'état de chez le député
j'ai annoncé ce matin que non seulement
nous étions prêts à reporter à étaler
les charges sociales et fiscales mais
pour les cas les plus graves à Montargis
ou ailleurs nous annulerons les dettes
sociales et fiscales des commerçants qui
ont été touchés mais je tiens à dire que
la première demande de tous les
commerçants partout sur le territoire
qui aujourd'hui sont inquiets ont peur
pour leur commerce ont peur pour les
activités c'est la fermeté c'est
l'autorité c'est la sécurité c'est soit
à quoi s’emploie le ministre de
l'Intérieur et le ministre de la Justice
et vous avez compris que la ligne du
gouvernement défendue par la première
ministre Istre est clair le
rétablissement partout sur le territoire
de l'autorité de l'Etat
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Naïma mucho pour
le groupe horizon
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre quand les parents
s'habitue à laisser faire leurs enfants
quand les enfants ne tiennent plus
compte de leurs paroles quand les
enseignants tremblent devant leurs
élèves et préfèrent les flatter quand
finalement les jeunes méprisent les lois
parce qu'ils ne reconnaissent plus
l'autorité de rien ni de personnes
au-dessus d'eux alors alors c'est là le
début de la tyrannie disait Platon dans
la République madame la Première
ministre les violences de ces derniers
jours symptomatiques de cette France qui
va mal
traversé par une crise d'autorité et
d'identité c'est violence ne seront pas
sans conséquence à court terme nous
devons rétablir l'ordre bien sûr mais
soyons clairs il ne sert à rien de
réparer ce qui a été abîmé si c'est pour
voir le chaos se reproduire ce ne sont
pas de nouveaux milliards dans les
quartiers ont besoin et la raison en est
simple ni la paix sociale ni le
sentiment d'appartenance à la nation ne
s'achète
la responsabilité d'une partie de la
classe politique dans ce qui se passe
est immense et je veux le dire c'est une
partie de la gauche qui a remis en cause
nos institutions justifiant l'usage de
la force et de la violence c'est une
partie de la gauche qui a nourri chez
les jeunes de quartier le sentiment
d'ostracisation la haine de la police et
de l'autorité l'atmosphère d'une société
qui serait fondamentalement raciste
je voulais dire car je l'ai vu à
l'oeuvre je l'ai entendu venir nous dire
cette gauche dans ma petite cité HLM du
Val-d'Oise je l'ai entendu dire la
France vous rejette vous n'y avez pas
votre place cette partie de la gauche
n'a laissé aucune chance à ces
populations pour espérer faire nation
pire pire pour elle elle pense
aujourd'hui tirer un bénéfice politique
du désordre mais elle finit par battre
en retraite car elle ne maîtrise rien et
à la fin ce sont ses meilleurs ennemis
qui essayent d'en tirer parti ses
meilleurs ennemis de l'extrême droite
mais chers collègues une nation ce sont
elles ne se venge pas il est urgent que
nous fassions fronc commun madame la
Première ministre vous avez reçu les
gros politiques comment ensemble peut-on
faire nation
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier Véran
porte-parole du gouvernement et ministre
chargé du renouveau démocratique merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députés
Naima mucho vous faites à travers votre
question un panel de ce qui a pu
éventuellement provoquer les scènes de
violence auxquelles nous avons assisté
et en reliant cela d'ailleurs à des
questions politiques je vais essayer de
vous répondre en vous rappelant qu'elle
était d'abord l'action du gouvernement
depuis le premier jour 1 restaurer
l'ordre de maintenir l'ordre 3 ne jamais
perdre de vue ces objectifs de garder
l'ordre pour les territoires les
premières victimes sont les commerçants
sont les pompiers sont les gendarmes
sont les policiers sont aussi les
habitants des quartiers qui ont vu des
services publics incendiés qui ont vu
des magasins décimés qui ont vu des
vitrines et d'entrée et qui se sentent
eux-mêmes aussi victimes de l'image
de l'image que ces jeunes ont pu
renvoyer sur l'ensemble des quartiers il
faudra évidemment nous interroger non
pas pour excuser madame la députée c'est
pas le sens de votre question il sera
intéressant à ce titre par exemple il y
a 4000 personnes disaient le garde des
sceaux bientôt 4000 personnes qui ont
été interpellés beaucoup comparaissent
devant la justice d'autres le feront
dans les prochains jours il sera
intéressant de regarder à qui nous avons
affaire à quel moment des jeunes de 12
ans de 13 ans peuvent se retrouver au
milieu de la nuit un bidon d'essence à
la main pour mettre le feu à pavillon ou
une pierre à la main pour casser une
vitrine il a été question à juste titre
de la responsabilité parentale je crois
pas qu'il faille chercher madame la
députée dans les dans les cris je crois
pas qu'il faille chercher aujourd'hui
une réponse toute faite et nous avons
besoin d'apprendre pour que ça ne se
reproduise plus et vous avez raison de
dire que la réponse ne sera pas dans un
déferlement de dépenses publiques dans
ces quartiers mais il nous faudra
arriver à saisir les tenants et
aboutissants comment encore une fois des
jeunes de cet âge-là ont pu en arriver à
cela ensuite madame la députée d'un mode
de façon plus politique pour terminer ma
réponse les habitants des quartiers
concernés auxquels vous faites que vous
évoquez non peut-être pas d'ailleurs de
partis politiques en prof mais ils ont
de la mémoire et ils seront se souvenir
tôt ou tard de qui était à leur côté
pour restaurer l'orgue les services et
qui a tenté les Instrumentalités
la parole est à Madame Nadège amour
bangoli pour le groupe la France
insoumise madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre de la Justice il faut être
présent si nous on n'est pas parents a
dit le président de la République
arrogance mépris de classe et
humiliation supplémentaire pour les
parents des quartiers populaires
l'explosion qui a suivi le meurtre de
Naël et le symptôme de votre échec votre
échec a en finir avec les violences
policières et au-delà avec le racisme la
relégation sociale alors au lieu
d'apaiser vous rejetez la faute sur les
autres sur les faibles et vous les
humilier comme vous avez humilié celles
et ceux qui alertent depuis des
décennies vous humilier ses parents au
métier pénibles qui se battent pour
leurs enfants ses parents applaudis
pendant la crise du covid et insulter
aujourd'hui
ignomini supplémentaire le président du
Medef déclare que le premier employeur
en Seine-Saint-Denis est le trafic de
drogue quel mensonge et qui a le honte
vous humilier vous insultez ma mère
femme de ménage elle a élevé 5 enfants
Épinay sur scène en Seine-Saint-Denis
vous humilier Elena d'Aulnay qui court
les brocantes pour acheter des livres
qu'à l'école on manque vous humilier les
parents de l'association trouvent les
nous au Pavillon-sous-Bois qui luttent
pour trouver des orthophonistes des
psychologues pour leurs enfants vous
humilier ses parents du collège Pierre
Curie à Bondy qui se battent contre les
fermetures de classe vous humilier les
mamans d'Aulnay qui arpentent les rues
pour calmer les colères légitimes de
leurs enfants c'est maman demande
simplement les mêmes conditions sociales
que les autres pour éduquer leurs
enfants pas des leçons d'éducation car
aujourd'hui encore que leur
promotez-vous une justice expéditive
pour leur fils qui n'aurait pas rien et
qui abîme les vies et pour ses parents
jugèrent digne des sanctions financières
pour le président de la République
pénale pour vous en somme les vieilles
recettes de l'extrême droite ce n'est
pas la voix de l'apaisement et de la
réconciliation c'est de la folie il y a
des territoires perdus de la République
non il y a des territoires abandonnés
par la République c'est à cet abandon
qu'il faut mettre un terme avec une
politique de justice le seul ministre
les parents des quartiers populaires
assurent leur part pour l'éducation de
leurs enfants quand allez -vous enfin
assumer le vôtre
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Eric
Dupond-Moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice
[Applaudissements]
ce discours est absolument surréaliste
[Musique]
en réalité vous injuriez toutes les
femmes de ménage qui ont bien élevé
leurs enfants
[Applaudissements]
et ne vous en déplaisent madame la
députée en particulier la mienne moi je
n'ai jamais traîné dans les rues à 11
ans vous voyez
et puis et puis et puis naturellement
vous n'avez pas entendu le discours
nuancé que nous tenions bien sûr bien
sûr qu'il y a des parents qui font
beaucoup avec peu mais il y a des
parents qui ne font rien avec beaucoup
et c'est cela que nous visons voyez-vous
j'ai toujours dit que la maman qui
travaillait la nuit pour élever sa
famille et la maintenir ne pouvait pas
être incriminé mais en revanche les
parents qui laissent traîner leur monde
de 11 ans 12 ans 13 ans dans les rues
alors qu'il devrait être chez eux à leur
domicile il mérite qu'on les rappelle à
l'heure responsabilité vous êtes la
France incendiaire incendiaire
et à force de dire que les policiers
sont des meurtriers que la justice ne
vaut rien qu'on peut aller impunément
cramé des commissariats et des tribunaux
vous donnez un merveilleux exemple aux
enfants dont vous voudriez vous faire
les défenseurs
madame la députée
monsieur le ministre personne n'aime les
missionnaires armées
la parole est à Monsieur pas de Molac
pour le groupe merci Madame merci merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre délégué
chargé du logement je souhaite aborder
la question des zones tendues en matière
de logement ne se passe pas une semaine
sans que je sois interpellé sur les
difficultés à se loger lors du projet de
loi de finances 2023 nous avons voté
l'élargissement de nombreuses communes
pouvant être classées en zone tendue la
situation était critique par exemple en
Bretagne une seule zone tendue
l'agglomération de Nantes
ce classement permet de doter le conseil
municipal d'outils pour pouvoir réguler
le marché comme la surtaxion la
surtaxation pardon des résidences
secondaires l'application d'une taxe sur
les logements vacants ou la possibilité
d'encadrement des loyers pour la liste
des communes en zone tendue dévoilée par
le gouvernement nous semble trop
restrictive seul 2600 communes sont
concernées en France en Bretagne
administrative par exemple seulement 140
communes seraient concernées pourtant la
pression immobilière se fait sentir
partout d'ailleurs la région Bretagne
avait demandé à ce que toute la région
soit placée en zone tendue de plus
l'exclusion de certaines communes comme
Saint-Tropez Vannes ou encore la réunion
nous interroge monsieur le ministre
envisagez-vous de revoir votre copie et
détendre au-delà de 2600 communes
initialement ciblées le périmètre de
zone tendue nos territoires ont besoin
d'outils concrets pour lutter contre la
crise du logement faisant confiance aux
maires qui seront
utiles
[Musique]
je vous remercie merci beaucoup monsieur
le député la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier Klein ministre chargé de la
ville et du logement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Paul Molac vous l'avez rappelé la
modification du zonage et de la taxe sur
les locaux-vacances et la taxe
d'habitation sur les résidences
secondaires est une mesure forte de la
dernière loi de finance de la loi de
finance 2023 c'est l'issue d'un travail
de vous tous des parlementaires et le
travail sur les laboration de la liste
vient de se terminer ces 3693 communes
qui ont été choisies fruits d'un travail
de qualité entre le gouvernement et les
associations d'élus pour ces communes
qui ont été choisies ça va permettre au
maire parce que ça relève bien d'une
responsabilité des maires de décider
d'appliquer d'appliquer ou pas cette
taxe sur les locaux vacants et cet axe
cette taxe d'habitation sur les erreurs
secondaires ça va permettre aussi Homer
d'augmenter largement la possibilité
d'agir sur les meublés touristiques et
là encore c'est une décision de la
collectivité locale et il nous semble
important que ça reste une décision de
la collectivité locale avec mes
collègues Olivia Grégoire et Dominique
Faure vous le savez vous en faites
partie nous animons une commission de
travail qui va se réunir le 18 juillet
de mémoire pour continuer à travailler
sur l'attrition du logement en zone
tendue parce que oui il y a un vrai
problème de logement partout mais en
particulier en zone littorale en
Bretagne en zone de montagne pour que
les habitants de ces territoires
trouvent à se loger une soixantaine de
mesures sont en cours d'examen elles
vous ont déjà été présentées nous allons
arbitrer ensemble sur les mesures qui
nous semblent le plus efficaces pour
continuer à travailler sur cette mesure
mais bien sûr pour que ces mesures
soient utiles il faut dans le même temps
que chacun prenne en compte cette
nécessité de construire partout et pour
tous l'ensemble de type de logement pour
que le parcours résidentiel puisse se
faire à l'intérieur des zones
touristiques parce que être une zone
touristique ça peut être une chance on
est souvent une c'est l'honneur de notre
pays d'être un territoire d'attrait mais
nous avons besoin de loger ce qui habite
et ceux qui viennent travailler pendant
les périodes estivales merci merci
oui monsieur le ministre je crois qu'on
est d'accord sur le fond c'était juste
simplement sur le nombre de communes je
crois qu'il est important comme vous
l'avez rappelé comme je l'ai dit ce sont
des outils que l'on donne aux maires ils
peuvent les utiliser ou non ils en ont
plusieurs et je crois qu'il est
important effectivement qu'on puisse
ouvrir cette panoplie d'outils au plus
grand nombre aujourd'hui par exemple
dans une zone qui n'est pourtant pas
très touristique j'ai des gens qui sont
obligés d'aller au camping parce qu'ils
travaillent à côté et qu'il ne trouve
pas de logement
voilà nous devons répondre à ça je vous
remercie monsieur le député la parole
est à Madame Nadia est pour le groupe
Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur le mardi 27 juin
au matin nous doute découvrions avec
horreur la mort du jeune Naël par le tir
d'un policier suscitant une émotion
immense dans tout le pays jusqu'au
président de la République le même mardi
soir nos concitoyens découvrent avec
terreur la destruction et le saccage
organisées dans nombre de nos villes
suscitant la colère de nos habitants
face à la destruction inacceptable de
leurs écoles de leur mairie de leur
transport de leur service public de
leurs hôpitaux de leur commissariat ou
encore de leur commerce dans ces moments
de crise l'heure n'est ni à l'analyse ni
aux propositions aussi farfelues
soient-elles l'heure est à la fermeté
tolérance zéro face à ses actes
inacceptables c'est pourquoi je salue
l'action de la justice je me joins aussi
à l'hommage appuyé à nos forces de
l'ordre et aux pompiers qui ont été mis
à rue des preuves pour nous protéger
hommage avec la même force aux élus
ainsi qu'à ses mamans qui ont relayé
l'appel local hommage aussi à ces jeunes
qui ont pris la parole pour condamner
ses actes et pour s'en désolidariser des
joints ainsi les plans
d'instrumentalisation de ceux qui
voulaient utiliser les jeunes des
quartiers comme un bouclier à leur
projet politique essayant péniblement de
masquer la trahison de la gauche
vis-à-vis de nos quartiers
honte honte à ceux qui ne se sont pas
levés pour l'appel au calme honte à ceux
qui profitent de l'occasion pour nourrir
leur haine monsieur le ministre vous
êtes un enfant des quartiers tout comme
moi nous appelons à ce que l'agissement
d'un seul policier ne doit pas jeter les
discrédits sur toute notre police
nationale qui nous protège et qui nous
honorent tout comme nous appelons à ce
que la conduite inexcusable d'une
minorité de jeunes des quartiers ne doit
pas jeter le disc rédit sur l'ensemble
des jeunes de nos quartiers populaires
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre le
lien entre la police et la population a
été question paroles
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre Nadia
est-ce que ce jour-là
à Nanterre lors de ce drame qui a touché
ce jeune conducteur
le ministère de l'Intérieur les
autorités de l'État ont menti sur ce
qu'il s'est passé
la réponse est non
est-ce que ce jour-là le policier qui
est l'auteur de ce coup de feu a été
interpellé et mis en garde à vue la
réponse est oui est-ce que ce jour-là
après étude comme le droit tout citoyen
de ce qui s'est passé il a été mis en
examen c'est à dire qu'il y avait des
indices graves et concordants qui le
confondaient et déférer pour être mis
devant la destruction une information
judiciaire ouverte des chefs
d'accultation de meurtre ouvert émis en
détention provisoire la réponse est oui
il n'y a pas deux types de justice
il n'y a pas la justice pour les
puissants pour les agents publics pour
les efforts de l'ordre et pour les
autres citoyens et tous ceux qui
colportent le mensonge s'applent l'État
de droit tous ceux qui déforment la
vérité comme vous l'avez fait vous élus
de la France insoumise avec abjection et
avec sans doute la délectation de voir
ces révoltes ces commerces pieds c'est
mairies brûlées ces écoles ou les
enfants d'entrepris en vacances ces
policiers c'est magistrats ces élus dont
on met l'adresse sur des sites internet
pour appeler à la vengeance alors oui il
y a deux types de comportements ceux qui
seraient publica qui respectent ta droit
qui mettent les règles votées par les
banques parler parlementaires la
déontologie en premier et ceux qui
choisissent le chaos pour mieux pousser
leurs forces politiques alors vous
madame la députée qui connaissait bien
ses quartiers vous savez que les
policiers souvent sont issus de ces
quartiers aussi et que les habitants de
ces quartiers ont besoin de la police
alors nous devons travailler avec toute
la nation et distinguer le bon le bonbon
grain livré oui nous devons être fort
contre les policiers qui ne respectent
pas la loi et on doit être très dur
contre les délinquants qui les attaquent
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Émeline carbidy
pour le groupe GDR
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre et concerne la
cagnotte de soutien en policiers qui a
tué Naël en 5 jours cette cagnotte
atteint déjà plus d'un million d'euros
bien plus que son montant c'est son
existence même qui me choque et plus
encore le silence assourdissant du
gouvernement à son sujet
dans ce moment de crise que traverse
notre pays nous vous avons entendu
appelé à la responsabilité des parents
exiger de la justice plus la plus grande
fermeté multiplier les interpellations
mais s'agissant de la cagnotte vous avez
timidement annoncé qu'elle ne
contribuait pas à l'apaisement ces
petits voilà une cagnotte créée par un
membre de l'extrême droite qui organise
une récolte de fonds pour aider le
meurtrier d'un mineur ne voyez-vous rien
de choquant de profondément immoral de
manifestement illégales à l'existence de
cette cagnotte pourtant l'on se souvient
de votre vie réaction à propos de la
cagnotte qui avait été créée
pour Christophe Dettinger cette cagnotte
fermée par le site après insistance du
gouvernement madame borne ce sont vos
propos vous déclariez à l'époque le
succès de cette opération est choquant
est-ce normal de vouloir apporter un
soutien ce monsieur qu'on a vu frapper
un policier à terre qu'on a vu boxer un
policier il faut aussi que chacun
reprenne un peu ses repères aujourd'hui
c'est vous c'est vous qui avez perdu vos
repères madame la Première ministre dans
la Fernel un jeune a perdu la vie
n'est-ce pas moins choquant à vos yeux
votre inaction a-t-elle avoir avec la
connivence de votre gouvernement avec
l'extrême droite et leur volonté
d'instrumentaliser cette cagnotte pour
mettre à nu les fractures de notre
société si ce n'est au nom de la morale
madame le Premier ministre agissez au
moins au nom du droit cette cagnotte
cause un trouble à l'ordre public et sur
le fondement de l'article 1162 du Code
civil vous avez la possibilité vous avez
le devoir d'agir qu'attendez-vous pour
le faire
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Gérald Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente de la député
je me suis exprimé sur cette question
voilà quelques instants la première
ministre très clairement également voilà
48 heures non madame la députée ce n'est
pas au pouvoir exécutif de pouvoir se
substituer aux décisions judiciaires et
dans le cas dans le cas précis que vous
évoquez précédemment dans la même
expression du gouvernement il appartient
comme c'était le cas lorsque cette
personne avait attaqué un policier au
tribunal de prendre la décision
d'appliquer le Code civil et de faire
fermer cette cagnotte madame la députée
je voudrais cependant dire ici et sans
se dire quoi que ce soit puisque aucun
membre du gouvernement n'a créé cette
cagnotte quand même la député que si on
pouvait respecter deux principes le
premier principe d'équilibre et de
pondération le pays n'est-il pas déjà
assez éruptif et nos concitoyens
n'a-t-il pas de tous les responsables
politiques de ne pas utiliser chaque
prétexte pour faire de la politique
politicienne
deuxièmement y compris ce policier qui a
été mis en examen qui a été mis en garde
à vue et qui était dans tension
provisoire ce policier comme toutes les
personnes qui n'a pas été condamné par
la justice définitivement a le droit à
la présomption d'innocence si nous
respectons ces deux équilibres nous
rappelons que ce n'est pas le ministre
de l'Intérieur qui applique la justice
mais la justice qui applique les codes
civils que vous votez ici je crois que
la République sera alors bien gardée
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
madame carbidy je vois qu'il y a
visiblement deux poids de mesure parce
que dans l'affaire précédente madame
borde et Madame Schiappa ne s'était
absolument pas gêné pour dire que cette
cagnotte était une honte et c'est bien
parce qu'elles étaient intervenues que
la cagnotte avait été suspendue et la
justice merci madame la députée
la parole est à Madame Justine Gruet
pour le groupe les républicains
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre depuis plusieurs jours
la France offre aux yeux du monde un
bien triste visage des images de
violences urbaines inacceptables des
ménils pasteurs à Dole dans le Jura
jusqu'à la tentative lâche d'assassinat
du maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses Vincent Jean
Brun je souhaite m'associer aux nombreux
témoignages de soutien à son égard à sa
femme et à ses enfants
son engagement au quotidien comme celui
de tous nos mers et remarquable et doit
être salué tout comme doit Léa
trigalement l'immense courage de nos
pompiers de nos gendarmes de nos
policiers nationaux et municipaux qui
sont les gardiens de la paix et de
l'ordre républicain être élu c'est
prendre ses responsabilités lorsque
l'ordre est menacé dans notre pays c'est
sanctionner fermement et rapidement
lorsqu'une minorité violente détruit
tout le dire c'est bien tous n'ont pas
cette clarté dans l'hémicycle mais agir
c'est mieux les forces de l'ordre sont
confrontées à des émeutiers de plus en
plus jeunes entre 14 et 18 ans et de
plus en plus déterminé c'est un terrible
aveu d'échec en matière d'éducation et
de responsabilisation des parents
auxquels nous voulons pas nous résoudre
madame la Première ministre nous
attendons de votre part des actes forts
pour établir l'autorité dans notre pays
et lutter contre la défaillance de
certains parents
l'heure n'est plus aux paroles vide et
aux demi mesures en matière d'éducation
il faut passer urgemment à l'action pour
réaffirmer les valeurs de notre
République cela passe par une école
forte une école qui valorise le goût de
l'effort et le respect du corps
enseignant mais une école qui ne se
substitue pas aux parents qui ont des
droits et des devoirs notre famille
politique avait fait voter une loi en
2010 qui retirait une part d'allocations
en cas d'absentéisme à l'école abroger
en janvier 2013 alors que la gauche
était au pouvoir ma question est donc
simple êtes-vous désormais capable de
reprendre cette mesure et de sanctionner
les parents qui ont démissionné dans
l'éducation de leurs enfants je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur
Eric Dupont-Moretti garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice
madame
la députée
je crois que
les raisons qui ont amené
assez violentes absolument incalifiable
insupportable dénoncé par presque tout
le monde ici
ce sont ce sont à l'évidence des raisons
multiples
plurifactorielle
ces choses sont très difficiles et on
retrouve j'allais dire des clivages
traditionnels entre ceux qui disent rien
n'a été fait en matière de politique de
la ville et d'autres qui disent des
choses ont été faites et puis ceux qui
disent voilà ce que nous avons fait
matière d'éducation peut poser un
certain nombre de questions de respect
de nos institutions police justice
évidemment et les choses naturellement
ne sont pas simples j'ai d'ailleurs
demandé au procureur de me faire
remonter leur analyse précise sur non
seulement l'âge mais les motivations des
jeunes que l'on a retrouvé en train de
commettre des exactions pourquoi il y a
un discours simpliste qui consiste à
dire c'est le déterminisme ce que l'on a
entendu tout à l'heure voyez-vous et ce
que l'on entendra encore qui est un
discours de déresponsabilisation
absolument insupportable et puis
moi je je pense je pense tout simplement
que que nos mettre en avant que le
déterminisme saigner notre liberté c'est
pas plus compliqué que ça parce que
comme je l'ai dit il y a un instant il y
a des femmes de ménage qui élèvent bien
leurs enfants et il y a des enfants qui
ne commettent pas des infractions donc
tout cela tout cela tout cela tout cela
est une question de nuance et je
voudrais redire à la place qui est la
mienne que Gérald Darmanin et moi nous
assumons la réponse que nous avons
apporté en homme en personnel et nous
rendons hommage évidemment tous ici aux
policiers au gendarmes aux pompiers au
magistrat au greffier qui ont été au
rendez-vous de nos obligations alors
madame
fini monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
[Musique]
la parole est à Madame Blandine Broca
pour le groupe démocrate
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre surgit des PME et du commerce
on est abasourdi c'est toute une vie qui
s'arrête ces mots ce sont les mots des
très nombreux commerces en piller ces
derniers jours partout en France je
souhaite ici au nom du groupe démocrate
porter leur voix la voix de ceux qui
sont le cœur de nos centres-villes de
nos Bourbourg de nos quartiers la
plupart d'entre eux souffraient déjà
souffraient de la désaffection liée à la
concurrence de concentration en
périphérie à laquelle s'ajoute celle de
la vente à distance puis il eut les
gilets jaunes et puis le covid enfin une
respiration une bouffée d'oxygène mais
non les saccages et pillages de ces
derniers jours sont venus ruiner le
gangpin de nos commerçants qui voient à
leur travail détruit anéantis sous leurs
yeux au final ce sont plus d'un milliard
d'euros de dégâts et quid de l'impact
sur le tourisme au début de cette
période estivale
en 2022 l'assurance multirisque perte
d'exploitation a augmenté de 10% en 2023
de 8% combien pour l'année prochaine
alors même que seul un commerce en sur
deux souscrit une assurance perte
d'exploitation sans parler des
franchises qu'il faudra payer
immédiatement des employés qu'il faut
payer à la fin du mois des aménagements
qu'il a fallu qu'il faudra encore payer
pour tenter de sécuriser toujours plus
ça devanture son commerce face à ce
désarroi profond l'État doit répondre
présent aussi madame la ministre comment
pouvons-nous prévoir l'accélération des
procédures de permis de reconstruire
pour les magasins détruits en effet
au-delà du soutien financier la rapidité
des réponses à apporter est essentielle
et il enva évidemment de même du côté
des assureurs madame la ministre pour
toutes celles et ceux dont l'outil de
travail a été saccagé leur laissant un
sentiment de vie et d'oeuvre détruite
pouvez-vous nous détailler les mesures
que vous prendrez pour soutenir nos
commerçants et avant tout pour leur
permettre de travailler
c'est tout ce qu'il demande je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
députée la parole est à Madame Olivia
Grégoire ministre délégué chargé des PME
du Commerce de l'Artisanat et du
Tourisme merci madame la Présidente
[Applaudissements]
merci de vos mots madame la députée
brocard à l'endroit des commerçants et
notamment des commerçants indépendants
qui au nombre d'un millier à peu près
ont été touchés durant ces quelques
jours des meute je vous remercie aussi
d'avoir répété leurs mots j'ai eu
l'occasion d'être à leur côté ce matin à
Arpajon mais aussi hier Paris 15e
avant même de parler d'indemnisation
avant même de parler demain
je pense qu'il est très important aussi
de prendre la mesure de leur étape
psychologique et je tiens à vous dire
que
dans chaque préfecture de France les
conseillers à la sortie de crise
sont mobilisés bien sûr pour accompagner
les étalement de charges voir les
annulations de dettes fiscale et
sociales des commerçants qui auront été
les plus touchés mais je veux aussi dire
que les conseillers départementaux à la
sortie de crise peuvent accompagner
moralement les commerçants qui sont le
plus sidérés parce que je crois que le
mot qui fonctionne c'est le mot de
sidération
pour ce qui est de demain
nous avons déjà réuni à plusieurs
reprises avec Bruno Le Maire à la
demande de la première ministre les
assureurs mais aussi les banquiers nous
leur avons demandé deux choses que ce
soit rapide que ce soit simple pour que
ce soit plus rapide on va aussi laisser
le temps à la sidération de passer il
faut des jours pour que les sidérations
perdent passent donc les commerçants
n'auront pas 5 jours mais 30 jours déjà
pour se retourner vers leur assureur et
nous aurons dans les semaines qui
viennent le président de la République
vient de l'annoncer une loi qui va
porter la question des délais pour la
reconstruction à la fois sur le volet
des communes bien entendu qui ont été
touchées mais aussi pour accompagner les
commerçants et pour que ça se fasse le
plus vite possible dans le doute
deux réflexes à avoir très simple
premièrement porter plainte deuxièmement
appeler son assureur je me permets de
rappeler ses évidences dans le brouhaha
mais les évidences sont majeures je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre
[Applaudissements]
François pickman pour le groupe la
France insoumise
madame la Première ministre la mort du
jeune Noël tué par un policier montre à
quel point il convient de changer la
doctrine de la police c'était une des
propositions du plan présenté par
Jean-Louis Borloo en 2018 parmi d'autres
sur le transport la petite enfance la
culture le sport l'emploi les moyens
pour les communes la lutte contre les
discriminations ce plan était issu de
l'appel de Grigny qui réunissait plus de
1000 personnes des responsables
associatifs des élus locaux des mers qui
travaillaient sur un rapport dont le nom
fait écho aujourd'hui vivre en grand
vivre ensemble la République pour une
réconciliation nationale 19 grandes
mesures qu'on pouvait discuter mais qui
permettait de donner une nouvelle
ambition pour nos quartiers qu'il soit
situé dans les grandes ou les petites
villes quand on a fait monsieur Macron
il l'a jeté à la poubelle avec mes prix
arrogance tout le monde ici s'en
souvient
depuis quelle vision pour les quartiers
prioritaires de la ville aucune dans ces
quartiers comme ailleurs vous avez
dégradé les services publics par vos
politiques en matière de santé
d'éducation de justice de logement de
vie associative la force une nation
c'est la cohésion quelle cohésion
proposez-vous comme le dit si bien le
maire de trappes à lirabet à propos de
ceux qui refusent de construire du
logement social dans leur commune ce qui
croit pouvoir rester entre riches et qui
pensent que leur bonheur individuel ne
sera jamais heurté par un malheur
collectif organisé dans nos banlieues se
trompent lourdement ils seront tôt ou
tard rattrapés comme tout le monde l'est
aujourd'hui
les ghettos de pauvre n'existent que
parce qu'il y a des ghettos de riches il
faut finir avec le séparatisme de ces
derniers et y faire respecter aussi la
loi de la République
quels seront donc vos mesures pour
assurer cette cohésion pour remettre du
droit commun et des services publics de
qualité partout à fortiori dans nos
quartiers rappelons que les habitants de
ces derniers font partie des essentiels
qui rapportent plus à la société qui ne
perçoivent sans eux notre pays ne tourne
pas la parole est à Monsieur Olivier
Klein ministre délégué chargé de la
ville et du logement
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
pickman d'abord permettez-moi à mon tour
d'avoir bien évidemment une pensée pour
Noël une pensée pour ce sapeur-pompier
une pensée pour tous les forces de
sécurité qui ont travaillé
d'arrache-pied ces derniers jours une
pensée pour les élus une pensée aussi
pour l'ensemble des fonctionnaires et
des habitants de ces quartiers
populaires ensuite pour ce qui est du
plan Bordeaux ou du Deep plan Bordeaux
si vous le regardiez avec attention
comme nous le faisions nous vous verrez
que c'est une partie de l'inspiration de
l'action du gouvernement du quinquennat
précédent je veux rappeler les cités
éducatives dont le président de la
République a annoncé à Marseille dès
lundi soir son extension sur l'ensemble
des villes en politique de la ville un
axe important du plan Bordeaux et
d'ailleurs vous avez dit que ça ne
servait à rien il y a quelques jours
dans la presse c'est la rue lors du
quinquennat précédent nous quand nous
avons pris la direction de ce pays il y
avait 5 milliards pour la rue il y a 12
milliards et l'État est revenu au
financement de la rue alors qu'il avait
disparu lors précédent l'anus c'est
aujourd'hui plus de 1500 chantiers
partout en France parmi les 453
territoires en quartiers en rue passés
en convention 445 sont déjà en chantier
ce chantier marche et ce chantier est
extrêmement important le plan Borlo
c'est moins d'enfants dans les dans
l'école c'est donc la
séparation des CP à 12 les CE1
l'extension dans les grandes sections et
le président de la République l'a
annoncé à Marseille c'est l'accueil des
enfants des deux ans dans les prochaines
rentrées et l'augmentation des moyens
pour les moyennes sections le plan Borlo
c'est plus de culture dans les quartiers
populaires c'est les microfolies que le
gouvernement a continué à accompagner
tout au long du quinquennat précédent et
à développer ses 150 microfolies dans
les quartiers populaires c'est
extrêmement important pour les enfants
de ces quartiers le plan Borloz est plus
de culture c'est l'ouverture des
bibliothèques et là encore le
gouvernement précédent a accompagné
l'ouverture des bibliothèques sur des
horaires décalés en particulier le
dimanche le port Borlo a été mise en
oeuvre
merci merci
la parole est à Monsieur Denis masséglia
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre
l'incompréhension nous frappe tous
depuis une semaine
l'incompréhension tout d'abord face au
drame terrible qui est survenu à
Nanterre et qui a coûté la vie au jeune
âge à ses proches je redis notre
confiance en la justice pour faire toute
la lumière sur ce drame
l'incompréhension ensuite vis-à-vis des
troubles auxquels vous assistons depuis
plusieurs nuits et face auxquels nos
forces de l'ordre sont de plus que
jamais engagés je tiens à les en
remercier
une colère aveugle semble s'être emparée
de tout le territoire non seulement dans
les grandes villes mais aussi dans celle
moins de danse d'habitude plus calme je
veux pour preuve la ville de Cholet 56
000 habitants confrontés pour la
première fois à une telle violence je
comprends la colère quand elle dénonce
les discuter du quotidien mais je refuse
de comprendre la violence gratuite
quelle tente ici de justifier je refuse
de comprendre que les associations
retrouvent les pneus de leur véhicule
crevés que les commerçants découvrent
leur magasin pillés et que les élus
soient attaqués jusque chez eux Cholet
ce n'est ni une zone urbaine très dense
ni la ruralité
Cholet c'est une ville moyenne où il
fait bon vivre ou le taux de chômage est
de 4,6% où les entreprises ne demandent
qu'à embaucher Cholet c'est une ville
moyenne comme une existent tant en
France et dont les habitants ne
comprennent pas qu'une minorité ça cage
brûle attaque
sur ces territoires il ne manque
pourtant pas de sujets pour lequel se
mobiliser avec conviction mais dans le
respect je pense par exemple au manque
de médecins au manque de force de
l'ordre c'est là que doit se concentrer
notre énergie d'élus et l'accompagnement
des pouvoirs publics monsieur le
ministre que répondre au million de
Français qui vivent dans ces territoires
confronté quotidiennement à des
difficultés structurelles et à ce
sentiment de délaissement merci beaucoup
monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
massiglia
il y a 553 communes à la minute où nous
parlons qui depuis
le milieu de la semaine dernière ont
connu des dégradations de quelques types
que ce soit
il y a celle auxquels on pense qui ont
fait la une de la presse parce qu'il y a
des événements d'une gravité
particulière qui sont déroulées
il y a les grandes villes les quartiers
politiques de la ville et puis il y a
une géographie nouvelle dont on n'a pas
l'habitude dans ces 553 communes il y en
a 170 qui n'ont pas un quartier
politique de la ville et dans lequel les
explications et les raccourcis ne
sauraient expliquer ce qu'on a vécu dans
les autres nous en avons 120 dans
lesquels les habitants qui vivent en
quartiers politiques de la ville sont
moins de 3000 dans les communes dont
nous parlons
et ça le temps de l'analyse la volonté
du Président de la République de faire
en sorte de prendre le temps de regarder
les choses de regarder aussi quels sont
les profils de ces 4000 émetiés qui ont
été interpellés au-delà de leur moyenne
d'âge au delà de leur jeunesse qu'est-ce
qu'il est caractérise qu'est-ce qui nous
permet de mesurer ce que nous avons raté
si on se trompe sur le diagnostic on
aura des difficultés à amener les bonnes
réponses et pour être très concret Shola
est un bon exemple d'une ville qui est
dans le top 100 des communes où il fait
bon vivre d'une commune dans laquelle
effectivement il n'y a pas de
difficultés de ce type qu'on avait pu
repérer lors des émeutes de 2005 ou
depuis est-ce que c'est comme on le dit
la propagation aussi par les réseaux
sociaux qui fait qu'à un moment on s'est
senti des communautés de destins est-ce
que c'est lié à la haine contre les
institutions est-ce que c'est le
prétexte qui permet ensuite de commettre
des actes de prédation ce qui est
certain Monsieur le Député c'est que
derrière votre question il y a la grande
interrogation qui devrait au-delà du
droit véritablement nous interroger
prendre les quelques minutes non pas
pour que chacun ressorte de la boîte le
rapport dont il pense qu'il est la
solution la proposition qu'il avait
faite lors de la dernière présidentielle
mais au contraire regardez les yeux dans
les yeux ce dont nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui merci Monsieur le Ministre
la parole est à Madame Marine Le Pen
présidente du groupe rassemblement
national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
au moment où notre pays vient d'être
livré au saccage au pillage et à une
rage incendiaire insensé je voudrais
vous poser la question que se pose tous
les Français qu'avez-vous fait de la
France vous qui menez la même politique
que vous prédécesseurs depuis 40 ans
qu'avez-vous fait de notre pays en y
implantant des zones d'un endroit que
vous avez laissé ce communautariser ce
criminaliser qu'avez-vous fait lorsque
vous avez laissé prospérer l'ignorance
de notre culture l'hostilité à l'égard
de l'autorité légale de l'État
l'illégitimité de nos lois et la haine
de notre peuple qu'avez-vous fait pour
transformer notre pays parmi les plus
courtois les plus élégants et les plus
doux de la terre pour en faire un enfer
ou ce qu'on suive avec les bâtiments
publics qui brûlent toutefois en
l'avenir
ce spectacle afflige le monde entier et
notre pays qui fut tant admirer pour son
rayonnement intellectuel et sa puissance
suscite aujourd'hui la pitié quand ce
n'est pas l'ironie vous n'avez tiré
aucune leçon des émeutes de 2005 pas
plus du Stade de France qui laisse
augurer un désastre sécurité pour les JO
de 2024 et avec lui une nouvelle
humiliation nationale la vérité c'est
que vous n'avez voulu entendre aucun
avertissement ce qui arrive nous
l'avions prédit malgré une grande
adversité je le dis avec tristesse et
gravité nous avons eu malheureusement
raison au moment où vous vous apprêtez à
nous resservir un coup de milliard à
énième plomb banlieue je vous appelle au
courage de l'autocritique à l'humilité
d'admettre l'échec dramatique de vos
politiques il faut d'abord et avant tout
stopper l'immigration anarchique or vous
êtes en train d'aggraver le problème du
communautarisme voire du séparatisme et
de le disséminer dans le moindre village
il faut ensuite reprendre la main dans
tous les quartiers de France rétablir
l'autorité des parents refaire de
l'école le creuset de la République
rendre à la justice sa fermeté sans
laquelle elle restera impuissante à
protéger les Français merci au cas de la
sécurité économique et judiciaire merci
possible la nationale
la parole est à Madame Elisabeth borne
première ministre
[Musique]
madame la première minute
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la Présidente Le Pen alors oui madame la
Présidente j'ai écouté avec beaucoup
d'intentions votre intervention et j'ai
cru un instant qui pourrait y avoir des
propositions mais jusqu'au bout jusqu'au
bout vous démontrez une fois de plus la
seule chose dont vous êtes capable c'est
la caricature et vous voyez madame la
Présidente je regrette même si ça ne me
surprend pas beaucoup que le choix que
vous faites c'est celui de la division
et quand j'entends le président de votre
partie opposée les territoires ruraux et
les quartiers comme si aider les uns
devaient dépouiller les autres je me dis
décidément vous n'avez pas changé et
quand j'entends encore à l'instant
pointé certaines parties de notre
population je me dis de nouveau les
caricatures vraiment vous n'y échapperez
pas je pense que aujourd'hui alors que
notre pays alors que de nombreux maires
vivent des situations difficiles alors
que des commerçant Eden artisans on fait
face à beaucoup de violences ne pas
jouer l'unité du pays c'est ce n'est pas
responsable madame la Présidente Le Pen
ça n'est pas responsable
alors voyez pour notre part nous serons
toujours on soutient de nos policiers de
nos gendarmes de nos sapeurs-pompiers
des policiers municipaux des élus locaux
et nous serons tous toujours mobilisés
pour lutter contre la violence mais nous
sommes également mobilisés pour lutter
contre le poison de la division et quand
notre République est attaquée c'est
l'unité nationale qui doit l'emporter je
vous remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre
la séance de questions au Gouvernement
est terminée la séance est suspendue